[Applause]
oh you can perfect
[Music]
what's up guys I am Thomas dobage
whatever you want to call me welcome
back to another episode of the dope as
usual podcast I'm with my co-host Marty
O'Neal what's up guys hello hi how's it
going guys this is the adobe's usual
podcast here to talk about life drugs
problems accomplishments and everything
in between before we start that I just
want to say I'm sorry if I feel off or
sound off I yesterday did a video
ate the Edibles drank the Edibles then I
forgot we had our trainer coming over
so an hour and a half after the video
I'm like oh yeah I'm with the trainer
today
did the training session which was dope
it was awesome sauna all that [__] but
it was hot did the sauna after the
training session go in during the cool
down where you shake your breather is in
the sauna oh God yeah it's like it's
like it's like called the hit workouts
or whatever anyway
I got violently dehydrated and sick
yesterday sounds about right I got
Michael's you know what's crazy it's
right before we didn't eat all it was
edibles
smoked a bunch went straight home
10 minutes before my workout no 15
minutes before my workout started didn't
eat and I'm like I have to eat something
I have to eat something right now
and I'm like I'm gonna pull Michael
Scott and I went in the fridge and there
was cold pasta from last night I ate
four spoons of cold pasta as I'm eating
it I'm like I hope I don't throw this up
at about minute 40 in the workout I was
just like
I just had pasta right here just I just
don't want it to start rolling out you
know when you're super dehydrated and
he's like you're not gonna throw up
Liquid it's just gonna come out in
Play-Doh chunks I was like that
I'll make it
up and then workout was done and smoked
the ball
I was like you know what I'm gonna die
I'm gonna die and I started drinking
water then I got ultra high
it's like all the Edibles hit me at once
what are we talking about
uh the dopa Shop new syrup and we're
introducing chocolate bars so it was my
first time really eating that much of
the chocolate bar 600 milligram
chocolate bar and uh I might be the
first person to overdose off hhc now the
chocolate's in the mix oh it's it's bad
it was the white chocolate birthday cake
bomb anyway
um what happened after that I tried to
go to oh two nights prior I slept for
two hours the night before or two nights
before three hours and the night before
that I slept for four hours because I
had [__] to do and I was up late
randomly so I'm here half asleep off
Edibles dehydrated so if I look like I'm
I went to bed at five o'clock last night
Jesus Christ I don't know what's going
on me
and I woke up this morning came here so
if I feel a little like
that's literally what we talked
yesterday yesterday somebody told me
they thought I was drunk yesterday on
FaceTime
it's like I've never seen you so like
struggling to keep moving forward I just
feel like every step I took was a chore
I was so dehydrated I just want to puke
but I was hungry but I couldn't eat
because I was so dehydrated and just
ultimately High the dopest pre-workout
not the [__] not for mouthfuls of pasta
and Edibles you shouldn't do that in the
Sun so that's what I did yesterday so
sorry
let's pick it up I'm trying to function
I've had a goofy ass couple days of
sleep too but I should have been just
blurry and just
because I went time zones I was not
sleeping normally got back we had to be
at the airport at [__] 4 AM uh to get
back here and then I just been editing
my ass off
so I'm right there with you yeah we had
a goofy week of guest booking and stuff
so we're here just catching up that's
how I feel right now yeah it's one of
those with my eyes while I'm standing in
the line
and then start moving once the line
moves like oh yeah have you ever been so
tired you're like
I'll sleep right now in between these
calls when someone's like oh I'll be
right back oh yeah you're good
sometimes I when I sleep really if I
like don't sleep enough or I'm really
tired then I can't sleep like I'll leave
oh for sure
I'm just at the point where I'm like I'm
I'm so D I've been chugging water
I still feel like
you know that feeling where you're just
like I have syrup in my body not one
that's how I feel like yeah I feel like
I'm moving like like Globs like I'm
moving like a like then like the uh
The Blob that's how I feel I don't feel
good I feel just tired and extra I don't
know what it is about the syrups from
the dope shop
I don't like the effect they just take
they they affect you too long
I feel like the next day I'm getting a
hangover off does it make a difference
if you like chug it in one shot versus
if you like that just always check them
I just didn't drink enough water anyway
sorry that's why I'm so lethargic
all right that's why my bad I'm trying
to pick it up
kind of snap into it and then I ate food
right now and it made me feel sick
so I'm definitely still dehydrated let's
go sorry
yeah so I'm back from Buffalo I'm
feeling good I just edited our new
Spotify video so this week I'm not sure
how we're gonna roll this out but we got
the beginnings of a whole new type of
video coming to the channel here we
talked about it in the end of last
episode so and after this we're gonna
film something so that's what we filmed
we filmed like a little breakdown of
Music three songs I'll pick three songs
talk about it real quick just more stuff
yeah it's fun more stuff I haven't
watched it yet Marty edited it and
watched later
um that should be cool it's gonna be
coming out on this channel
and uh yeah oh before we get into
anything brand new we do it all every we
do it every week we do it every we're
gonna do it every week
the giveaways we just talked about it so
what do you want to do for this week
I say because we have we have we added
four more things to our to our uh dope
as usual.com dope asusualpodcast.com we
had to form more like shirts and
sweaters should we just do another one
with all of that included too yeah
that's right very good plan so right now
another giveaway so this if there's four
more this should be like 450 worth of
stuff
right now what you're going to want to
do is in the comments of this episode
drop your Instagram name that's all you
got to do just like last week drop your
Instagram name in the comments of this
episode right now if you're here you're
watching do you wanna it's like what now
it's like nine items almost I think I
don't know we just added more items back
in stock we got the scribble hoodies my
favorite hoodie of all time and the
white tees and the black tees that
weren't available but now they are
stickers and then four more shirts so
it's like nine things and also on dope
asusualpodcast.com now we're accepting
all forms of payment so before it was
just PayPal now you go with your debit
card your credit card your uh Apple pay
or whatever and you can get anything off
the site yeah yeah all right so that's
what we're doing giveaway over the
screen if you want to be part of the
giveaway all you have to do is drop your
Instagram name in the comments of the
episode you're watching
shout out to everybody that's been
participating we've been giving away a
lot of cool [__] it's so cool seeing
that poster framed yeah no the one that
we did two weeks ago and we're keeping
track of making sure these things are
shipping out so thank you guys
everybody's getting their stuff okay
um so this week's winner we will pick
during this episode but you know what
for next week drop it like uh drop your
Instagram name in the comments we need
to like make a little flyer to put over
the screen yeah it's Time Boom drop your
net you know what I mean so there was 3
200 people that entered last week's sick
thank you all right good shot good
that's good episode that's a great way
to support everything and uh it was not
an age restricted episode last week guys
finally finally over a hundred thousand
views in three in four days
thank you come on thank you guys see
what happens when like people actually
see our stuff they're like oh yeah I
like the show it just goes to show we
have no guess it was just me and you for
three hours getting high as hell
did great
it's my favorite thing to do it's
perfect John once again super scared
like I need another week I miss another
week that's why it's another uh solo
episode because John
got scared again and then after he was
all done he goes
I don't have a haircut you little girl
you let us know when you're ready
because it was here in this room with
these headphones on going oh like don't
do that taunting the fan don't do that
because the fans are gonna get pissed
don't post that I'm gonna easily should
I post it like no then they're gonna
think we filmed one so go bug him John's
the dopest on Instagram go bug him tell
him to hurry up stop being so scared he
actually has a name on our live chat
called no balls John
I didn't make that up the fans did
because they're like this will have no
balls he's not ready to do this yet
hurry up FaZe Rain was supposed to be
here today but also last second he's
gonna be here this week so we got a
pretty good uh couple weeks ahead of us
guys
um
okay uh what time are we at right now
what can we can we smoke yeah yeah or
okay real quick guys
I want to start off by talking about
something sir important
you guys know
I will
bro I've literally drove on the wrong
side of the street in traffic
while smoking no I wasn't smoking a
joint or neither was I on the phone
but
I will do a lot of things to make sure
that the fans feel included all right
I'll always do that
forever you guys know that you know me
the reason I'm bringing it up
2021 I believe you guys know it's hard
DMS are hard
they're hard to keep up with especially
on Instagram but this I rarely answer my
Twitter DMs
because Twitter I don't use as much and
it's like dude I can't answer four
different platforms to him I don't think
I've ever gotten a DM on Twitter oh I
got so many on Twitter
an opening invitation you can start DM
me on Twitter I'm saying just keep it
Instagram because I check a lot of
Instagram ones but I opened a Twitter DM
a couple years ago like two and a half
years ago and um you know nice dude
super cool and I look at his profile and
the last thing he posted was like our
video like watching dopa's Yola Channel
it's like that's cool man thanks for
posting on Twitter [__] yeah you know so
I noticed he's in the comments he's in
the DM he DMS me a few times and we talk
like yo what's up man blah blah
they would talk a little more turns out
let's say let's say right here his name
is Ethan
uh shout out to Ethan Moore he's really
he's really cool dude super nice right
so we're talking more
and then I'm you know people putting
their bio or like their pin comment
and I know it's like oh Hospital picture
and I read more it's like damn this fool
has cancer so this guy's what 19 or 20
at the time
he has brain cancer stage four brain
cancer it was the worst thing you could
ever have as a damn kid and yes he's a
kid 18 19 years old he's still a child
so
you know this was watching our videos
dislikes our stuff I continuously talk
to him over the courses of of course
like the next six months
um he's a huge fan right so me and Rosie
sent him out a box said about some stuff
some signs [__] just periodically
sending him [__]
end of 2022 we talked about flying a fan
out here for one of the golden tickets
for the dopa shop
and he dm'd me on Twitter and goes yo
you ever consider like let me know I
would love to come out there
um and chill for a day and I'm not gonna
say like yo
there's a lot of fans a lot of fans want
to hang out I get that
but not a lot of fans are like 19
dealing with some [__] like you know
what
why not
that'd be awesome right
make his day and then I thought damn 20
years old or 19.
I can't legally smoke with you you know
like
I can't I can't do that
and then
a week later he DM me he's like yo just
letting you know I would love to come
out there you let me know
and you know I talked to a lot of fans
but this guy Ethan I know his face I
know his name and all that [__] I follow
him on Twitter right he's a fan I follow
him on Twitter I don't follow a lot of
people I just follow him like yo this
guy's so supportive he's dope as hell
he's nice as hell
so
I think February came along goes yo let
me know I would love to come out there
you know I talk to him and I go dude
when's your 21st birthday he goes I
turned 21 three weeks ago what he says
20 in your bio he just didn't change it
you know so I'm like oh you're 21 good
[__] so I'm like John there's a dude
um named Ethan he's got you know he's
got brain cancer and [__]
besides that he's a fan it would be sick
to fly him out here pick him up in the
Sprinter
chill you know just
give him a sick ass day
and then that's a week after I moved two
weeks after I moved
and then about a week later I I totally
spaced I talked to John and said yeah we
should do it you know what I mean like
yeah yeah let's plan this plan that in
the middle of a meeting I talked about
it I'm like yo there's somebody I want
to fly out here
so I forgot right a week later he DMS me
again I pick I answer I'm like yo talk
to the team we'll we'll schedule it
right we'll schedule it for this summer
that's how I thought we'll schedule for
this summer you come out
and uh we'll do the whole day yeah I
didn't tell what we're gonna do but in
my plan pick him up go to all the places
he sees in the videos get high as [__]
chill you know fun like a day with a fan
and um
March April
he hit me up in April and said yo
just want to know if you guys had talked
about it if you had a date please let me
know
I didn't see that DM that was in April
and then
obviously guys like I'm just never think
nothing's ever on purpose but
like I just spaced for like over five
weeks I just spaced out
on autopilot doing [__] doing the show
we moved back to the warehouse
you know what I mean I don't mean to
sound like a dick but I got the car I'm
like trying to do this stuff I'm trying
to get the car out trying to do that
it's nothing like that's not important I
like my car that's not what it was it
was the things in front of me going what
do you need to do this for The Re-Up
this for the dopa shop this for this
this okay sick
oh when I check my Twitter DM oh yeah
Ethan we got to get Ethan out here this
summer summer started a week ago I was
waiting for June July this is the time I
was waiting for
I didn't see his two DMS right I didn't
see his two DMS in March I mean May
and then three days ago I five days ago
I saw a comment says please DM me I get
a lot of those comments all right and I
try to DM those people back
I saw the same person DM me again or
comment again and again and again and
then two days straight please DM me
please DM me like dude chill and one of
them said please DM me is very important
so I just click the name saw the DM
and the DM was from them saying yo I
have a friend he just passed away he was
a die-hard fan of yours
and if you can give a shout out that'd
be great he watched you every day
I was like Dan that's sad bro the
picture was like you know like a
chunkier white kid
and I'm like damn that is so sad because
I always think like
somebody passed away and they were
watching our [__] so one of the last
thing they saw was like what we were
doing which is so weird to me like
that's [__] crazy
like man that's so awful of course I'm
damning the person of course
um
I got you that's I'm so sorry for your
loss
and I'm sitting there I'm like
damn dude I haven't talked to Ethan in
at least three weeks I gotta get on this
DM because he I told him like yo this
summer I like go figure it out and that
was my plan this summer so June July
but that was May that was a month ago I
haven't talked to him in over a month
month and a half maybe
so like I feel like a dick I'm like oh
my God let me hit up Ethan go to Twitter
DM hey Ethan here's my email please
contact me because the DMS you know get
a little lost just hit me up directly so
we can plan you getting out here you're
gonna mean the person like this will
pass away is my friend and I
automatically thought damn Ethan's sick
he said I gotta I gotta get him out here
like
this is it because it's July it's about
to be July I told myself I'm like I
gotta get on this I dm'd him
a couple minutes later I go back to
Instagram just to follow up with the
person
and they sent me another picture like
yeah this is my friend he passed away he
was a huge fan
and I look at the picture I'm like what
the [__]
and I send them a picture of Ethan's
profile from Twitter like this isn't the
same person is it
because when you go through chemo and
[__] like some people gain weight some
people lose weight some people get
really chunky in their face some people
get really skinny the picture I know of
Ethan is a bald kid this other one guy
had a beard the next one he was super
skinny with curly hair
is [__] the same Ethan
if I can
idea and I'm like this isn't the same
person please is it and then they're
like yeah that's my friend Ethan am I
from Washington
because I know Ethan's from Washington
long story I believe donating to his
like you know his GoFundMe and [__] like
his mom does it for him like you gotta
support that kind of [__]
and I remember thinking
I have to get confirmation is this the
same person
and it was the same dude Ethan Moore
yeah Ethan passed away last week I
realized they told me exactly what
happened what time he passed away Marty
we were filming the last week's episode
right here at the same exact time
like 1 30 on the 22nd I'm like oh that's
when we were filming bro
so it's like
somebody's like my friend passed away
and it automatically go dude I gotta hit
up Ethan what am I doing I told him June
July it is almost July I gotta update
him
right and one other thing I want to say
is Ethan had stage four brain cancer
he's a kid and every single DM he
started with don't mean to bug you
every one of them
Ethel didn't have that much time and he
was like yo I don't mean to waste your
time
which is the craziest [__] I've ever
heard like about the being the most
polite you could possibly be it's like
being shot and going I don't mean to bug
you but could you please help me
I damn if we always started with I don't
mean to bug you but bro you're not
bugging me totally cool what's up like
you're not bugging man
since I was talking to his friends and
his friends like dude you're you're on
his wall we watch you every single time
we come over
and then I found out he has a twin
brother and his twin hit me up he's like
dude all he talked about was your [__]
um the last day he was there we were
unless he was alive we were watching her
[__] in the hospital
and it's just really [__]
I feel it's not like I purposely went
[__] you no I was like oh there's a
certain time I'm gonna bring you out I
just should have done it in April you
know what I'm saying like I should have
done an April I know I was super busy
I'm like no no I want the time to get it
done I procrastinated and but in my head
I'm like oh dude in June July June July
was too late it was literally a week and
a half too late
which is insane huh yeah
his mom posted his memorial picture I'm
looking at my looks like it's a fun kid
and then I look and he's got the push
trees mask on
look at that last picture he posted for
his memorial he's got our [__] mask
on
and for a long time his profile was
probably watching double Zola
I just followed I just thought he was
such a like such a helpful like
supportive ass fun person I'm like dude
I gotta follow this dude
and then just over time like you know
this guy's cool we gotta we got to bring
him out here so I've been talking to his
mom
um on text and [__] and
um July 8th is this oh this will come
out before that July 8th is the service
it is in Washington screen over the
screen right now boom if you're in the
area go support go show up say goodbye
even if you don't know him just his
mom's there she one of the things she
says like I can't believe how many
people like love this fool like I'm so
happy and proud that this fool was such
a positive
person because so many people are
hitting her up like yo I love that fool
yeah there you go right over the service
there it is and they're gonna live
stream it and [__] and just
damn dude what a horrible thing for a
Cadets right
young as hell and I kept thinking like
dance was almost basically Rocco's age
but anyway yeah that like woke me up
that morning I got that procrastinating
on [__] I gotta stop waiting oh it's not
the right time kind of busy right now
bro are you really that busy right now
or can you just get it done
push off one thing and get scheduled
this
foreign
I don't know I think talking to
someone's friends is like we get you get
the real like gist of the person more
like it was just terrible just some of
the [__] they were texting me not bad
they're just like you were all like
you're a favorite [__] person he's on
you're on his wall because I gave him
autographed posters and [__] for his
wall like he puts above his bed
before I said that three two years ago
like that fool still had it
ah it just sucks dude I know you know
what's weird I talked about it a lot of
people like you're a piece of [__]
telling me that like damn bro
I didn't think that
I don't know if you get the story though
I [__] up I should have done it a
month ago instead of I planned it a
month later I was going to do it 190
percent
I just should have did it when I I just
hit it earlier things like that in life
happen and then you don't realize that
you should have did it faster until
really after it's too late
because then I was thinking all morning
like Justin I was in New York and made
for my mom's birthday that could have
did it then like I had time to go to New
York but I couldn't have time you know
then I started doing that like you got
time to go to New York
I [__]
it's just like
I don't know it's just [__] up
I just [__] up but I mean
but I mean he watched every every
podcast every episode every everything
everything
shout out to you Thomas you guys got to
connect and know who each other were and
yeah
that's horrible though it's just uh
yeah whenever I get people that DM me
about like you know I want to end it all
and stuff like that I always remind them
there's a lot of people that aren't here
I would give everything they possibly
could to trade places with you despite
what situation you're in just try to
think about that and start from there I
know it doesn't mean anything but yeah I
tell people that a lot like I always my
things like if you can breathe think and
plan
it's worth it like you could be
something something because there could
be an equation where you're real real
real grateful for that just breathing
yeah yeah
so yeah
that's uh I wanted to talk about that
shout out to Ethan
damn
sad day yeah part of the community you
know people feel that
um
yeah all right my bad
um well this beautiful Jack that we have
here is for [__] Ethan
look at the size difference in the
joints man you've been talking about I
love that you've been talking you know
what that is true I have been talking
um okay I know you have some notes Marty
let's bust a few of them's out oh
actually before that can I tell a story
of what happened this week of course yes
what's up guys taking a moment to say
thank you to one of our long time
sponsors this is manscaped so besides
being the best male grooming company on
the planet manscapes also is run by
really nice and awesome people with that
being said make sure you use our code
that's 20 off plus free shipping all you
got to do is go to manscape.com forward
slash Yola that's it Yola at checkout
that's our code you get 20 off of
everything and anything you see here
anything you see on the site and free
shipping guys it's summer and you know
what that means somebody might see your
balls hey you never know jumping in the
pool cannonballing into some [__] your
balls might come out make sure they
don't look nasty and you could do that
with the performance package 4.0 the
lawnmower 4.0 guys make sure your dick
and balls are fresh right here the crop
mops these crop mops are for your balls
they're ball wipes maybe you're going on
a date maybe you're at the doctor
getting a checkup you don't want to look
nasty you don't want to look gross make
sure you're not smelly this right here
is the body wash they have a two in one
conditioner shampoo manscapes got
something for everyone right here these
are boxers yeah these are the nicest
packaging you ever seen for boxers in
your life eight million people and 16
million balls cannot be wrong the number
one male grooming kit on the planet back
to the episode
oh I saw it oh you did [__] hilarious
foreign
did you mean for this particular person
to be over your shoulders okay I look
back and went feel me right now
like Mrs Doubtfire that's why I did the
face of this
because it was like am I okay is this
cool is it school
couldn't be somebody that would be more
horrified if they looked over their
shoulder and saw you gripping off a
[__]
so what you just saw for everyone
driving what did we just played over the
show was me taking a dab at a restaurant
with a group of old white people behind
me one in a huge wheelchair I mean and
not just regular old white people old
white people with money old whites with
attitude
oh
whites with attitude
so here we go can I tell you how this
happened and how I was dabbing in
Beverly Hills off rodeo in the day
like we got a weird life isn't it oh no
no the day gets crazy
there's
sometimes guys when I'm by myself
I will do this
just to make sure shit's real like I
look around like
nobody would believe this
I'm glad I have a reputation for not
lying because I nobody would believe
this
so
and I'll tell you when that point
happened when I went nobody would
believe this I'll tell you when it
happened let me start the day
actually
48 hours prior to
screen change John's all hey you want to
go on a [__] dab thing yeah yeah I do
because basically we're gonna take our
cars on a car run John has crazy cars he
always goes on car runs Cars and Coffee
the rallies all that [__]
I don't I don't like people driving me I
don't like that [__] I'm good I don't
want to be around a bunch of people
speeding I like to HotBox the car
not my thing
but I'm like all right Jonah go with you
he's like yeah we're gonna stop at a
restaurant hang out they're gonna go to
a place and dab and all that my cool
I don't know more information than we
can take dabs somewhere
and bring your car
right
so I get there
40 feet from Rodeo Drive in Beverly
Hills in the day across the street from
a very very very prestigious Michelin
restaurant one that John goes to a lot
I've been there
it's not like it's it's like an Arby's
it's it's a place where like 48 salad no
thanks one of those bougie [__] places
pull up restaurant right there on the on
the road
nice restaurant families older people in
button-ups
people with dresses
ladies holding their purses like this
[__] like that
I walk in I sit down
there's like six tables toward the back
of the restaurant where there's like an
outside patio
and there's a bunch of random people and
then people for the event it's like a
little event you could tell whether the
event when people have certain necklaces
with emblems and pendants like oh so
this is where the event is you have a
pendant on pendants are like basically
the watches for the glass Community like
all sick pinned it bro that's like your
oh yeah I got the sick one it's like
having a sick watch okay so I'm like oh
pendants this is where so this is where
the people are and I see John we sit
down
and I see someone bust a rig out and go
we're busting rigs out
he goes yeah yeah you can bring your rig
out go stop stop what you're saying stop
what you're saying you're telling me I
can bring my [__] rig out on the
table right now I had it all timer
pearls cue everything in my box I
brought it with me because I thought we
were going somewhere to dab I didn't
know that summer was the [__]
restaurant I pulled my [__] rig out
and I look around and go oh so all these
tables are just us they're not like
regular restaurant people the regular
restaurant people are four feet to the
right they're right there and inside
right so what you saw in the video was
the people inside I don't like to smoke
around old people so I would never smoke
if they were sitting next to me but they
were inside they can't get secondhand
smoke from that and they weren't paying
attention
so I bust my rig out I'm like
I can do this
I'm still don't believe anybody like I
can do this I can torch this right now
the waiter comes up and I'm like that
I know they're they know
right
torture my railing I'm gonna get
arrested
torture my rig up
look around I'm like holy [__] there's
seven rigs over there this is real we
can dab here
it was a set courses they were bringing
out it's a bougie restaurant and we were
dabbing
at the [__] table
with people just walking by the friends
walking by the front of the restaurant
we're tucked in the middle of the
restaurant but with the patio
the back parking lot's right there
people were walking into that restaurant
through our dabs about going the [__]
walking through definitely noticing [__]
there's Rigs and torches and full-grown
men torching a bunch of [__]
seven eight tables plus with five rigs
at each table just people just going
hard so I'm like okay okay that's cool
probably not five Briggs each tail but
you know and everybody could tell like
oh you either a Trapper or you own a or
a company I can tell by the way you look
when someone's 23 with a hundred
thousand dollar chain I'm like oh so
what industry are you in I'm pretty much
I could tell like oh so you [__] packs
okay I got you and I'm sitting there
I'm like I look back I see all those
people behind me the old people I'm like
dude please take this [__] video
right now this is what you call a viral
video we're at a nice ass restaurant
like get the table and me dabbing
nothing else I'll take care of the rest
that's where I went I started doing the
face like
the man on a lifted wheelchair behind me
what the [__] is happening so as we're
finishing up with the the lunch
those people get up and start coming out
and their cars are parked in the back so
they have to walk through our little
event
so
tall old white man comes out
picking up his pants though
looking around
oh
he's walking through doing the side
steps like not really going straight
just like walking sideways and me and
Tony are like who is he gonna yell at
it's picking one it's like a shark like
who are you gonna eat which one of you
are gonna do you gotta gotta pick
somebody
he's looking around
huh all right I'm like oh who's gonna do
it too
and he walks he gets to the very edge of
the [__] tables and there's one white
dude with a torch in his hand torching a
rig
and the old man comes behind him puts
both hand on his shoulders
like a little shake and goes
I almost caught a secondary back there
whoa and he walked off and all this goes
was that [__] real
no [__] way he almost got Second Hand
high he meant almost got a secondary
back there
he's old as [__] yeah I almost caught a
secondary
coolest [__] part I like his attitude
though his attitude was incredible and
then walked off into the midst you guys
are fogging out all the regular is just
awesome but outside we're out no the
regulars are inside and there's like a
couple tables in the front patio but I
mean it's we're outside it's going
straight up it's not weed smoke either
so it's not soup you don't you don't
smell it unless you know what dabs smell
like but like you're not probably gonna
smoke it and smell it
but the fact that he said that made my
day and then um we got we gotta line our
cars up about to take off
I've never drove with people never try
to keep up with people never done any of
that
it was pretty fun it was pretty fun
so like
it's all super cars hyper cars and like
sick ones so there's a lot of like it's
Grand Theft Auto cars you know Lambo
Lambo Lambo Porsche Porsche Ferrari
Ferrari Ferrari Ferrari calling in
Rolls-Royce this bunch of crazy ass cars
and here's me in my boat of a [__]
Maybach like I'll try to keep up with
you guys I might have a V12 but
it's a boat they got little Porsches
911's cutting zigzagging doing crazy
[__] right
so I'm like I'm gonna try to keep up
with you just give me the address in
case I [__] get dusted
so
here we are
going down Beverly Hills
sounds strong leaving Beverly it's very
stressful leaving Beverly Hills and you
have to stay together in the lights a
real GTA mission
so I'm driving
and everybody takes a left as I take a
right I was in the front I took a right
because that's the direction said I look
back at everyone's going the other way
so I call John I pull over I'm waiting
for eight minutes for them to line back
up so I can find them again everyone
went the wrong way there's 30 40 deep
six cars were with us
so I finally wait I hear John Hall and I
hear his exhaust like oh where I know
it's him
it's loud and I see him and I flip it
get behind him and we start
going through Beverly Hills and and
Century City like in the line of seven
different crazy cars
I'm like this is kind of fun trying to
stay up with everybody it's cool I kept
up I kept up so well I couldn't believe
it
there was a time I was going 85 just on
the street like
but I'm driving like no one is being an
[__] we're not cutting pools off no
one's dipping into [__] that you're like
whoa that was too risky what are you
doing no one's doing stupid [__] that's
why I stayed with them if they were
being dicks I would have just like
and just waited on my own and then drove
[__] I'm not gonna be one of those guys
but everybody was cool but I was just
we get to Malibu and I'm right behind
them I get stuck at one light and that's
when I lost them the last four minutes
of the drive I lost them from so I kept
up with these fools on the [__]
freeway kept up with all these dudes in
the line and there was one point where I
was in front of the lambo the whole time
there was one guy behind me and I'm like
yo this is kind of fun holy [__] I
wasn't smoking any weed because I was
like I got both hands of the [__]
steering wheel
get to Malibu we park
probably should have went somewhere else
all we did was smoke up a whole parking
lot everybody was just staring at the
cars and then going oh my God are those
porches
I was like dude why are we here just
torching in a parking this is weird
but the guy's like the guy that put the
van on his last week it was empty I
swear to God that's why I picked this
[__] part of the beach it's like I
didn't want to be around people and when
we park and this is where I went
this is real I gotta look around like
this is no something's out something's
fake ready guys
we leave we're going to a house in the
Hills that they rented so that's where
we're gonna go smoke at
I'm driving I post this on Instagram or
I posted this on Instagram where the
cars are the maybach's in front of me
bouncing
right and then there's a Ferrari in the
Porsche and all the crazy cars all lined
up like this is Grand Theft Auto
this is Grand Theft Auto if I've ever
been if I've ever seen it we're on the
beach in Malibu it looks just like a
video game
so we take off and this is when I'm like
no no one is with me this isn't real
I'm driving
there's a Maybach truck next to me
couple Lambos behind me and I'm like
this is the little kid in me is going
are you [__] me this is awesome
there's so many cool cars like this is
so fun
a couple Porsches Lambos and [__] behind
me in front of me
we're all like doing this
staying together
and I was supposed to meet up with
Franklin that night from Grand Theft
Auto
I'm supposed to meet up with him that
night because we're going over some
stuff
he calls me in the middle of this car
run and I'm zipping so I put him on
speaker
I have them on speaker
and all I hear as I'm whipping through
back through Beverly Hills into the
Hollywood Hills as I'm whipping through
in the hills and all these cars I just
hear what's up man I'm like what's up
what's up Sean you know no I'm just
chilling I just hear Michael's voice hey
man what so yeah I'm with uh and he says
his real name he's like you know the you
know God plays Michael because I was
supposed to meet with both of them but I
got back too late all I know is I'm
driving
whipping fast
look at my rear view nothing but
Ferraris and Lambo look in front of me
Porsches and Ferrari and I hear Michael
and Franklin and I'm like yeah man I'll
meet you guys up I'll probably call you
around 7 30 I'm on the car run I'm
trying to keep up and then they're like
oh yeah for sure man all right cool hey
and I hung up
and that's when I went
the [__] is going on the closest
anybody's ever been in real life this is
the closest that you can get to Grand
Theft Auto in life you can you cannot
get closer
than that it was one of those moments
where I went if this is The Truman Show
I'm down you guys did a great [__]
job you did a great job on this season
like this is a great season 30s it's
good season because
what the [__] is happening nice to
remember I look back and when I saw
that line of cars doing this behind me
and then the call and I can hear their
both of their voices I was like
what
wrote this [__] yeah who wrote this my
Uncle John would lose his [__] mind
right now I would have called him
immediately like bro what the [__]
anyway go to the [__] uh the Mansion
the mansion's a [__] Grand Theft Auto
House walking you saw the [__] view
I'll show you a little clip in insert
clip wow
anyway we just dabbed there a bunch of
smoking then we go to this Michelin
restaurant and they let us dab in there
10. it's in the [__] Continental
Hotel
hold on hold on different restaurants
different restaurants two places we go
and it's like Korean barbecue so they
have big fans
it's a really high-end restaurant where
they have Kobe beef those little steaks
they bring on floating smoking boards
one of those places
you've got them to agree to the shed
wasn't my event they did it but down the
hall went on one Hall of the nice ass
restaurant and opens up to like 50
chairs 50 tables like I mean nothing
here tables for big enough for like 50
people right with all the grills and all
they did was put up one of the things
that girls get changed behind a little
unfolding thing yeah blocked off the
hallway and we had our they had like arm
guard everywhere we went because you
know the cars and [__] and the Griggs
in the jewelry these fools all the
Trapper kid looking kids you know the
Trapper kids and uh
they had him standing at the front right
there at the at the entrance of the
hallway
and now and the whole restaurant's
packed with people
not one of them knows if they go like
this
all they had to do is look all over the
curtain
see 75
clubs I rip I was smoking my ass up we
had one of the waitresses fill our rig
with her with her water thing
videos coming soon
um
yeah
yeah how did the waitresses they were
all they were all with it
there's a 20 course dinner
not one of the people part was vegan so
I just ordered
I just had a lemonade
I did get a lemonade and I got some
mushrooms and rice and corn all right
all right well it's all right I still
ate [__] it's just like
this is it was insane it was crazy bro
but parking all it was just crazy
rolling around going I love that car wow
I love that car holy [__] I love that
car you know in GTA when you steal a
good car a nice car and then all of them
start spawning that's how I feel that's
how I felt grab that thought of real
life
that's gonna be a good clip but Marty
Clips this for Instagram oh that's Taco
that whole story is going to be in one
little clip and it's gonna be great
um so yeah that's what I did this
weekend that was nuts so this is like
some sort of club or some show yeah it's
a club it's a social club
um you know the social club they like do
a certain amount of people every so
often it was epic if I do anything else
with them I'll announce you guys let you
know what it is but
unbelievable it sounds crazy it was
crazy
I bet John was enjoying himself he was
trying pretty hard yeah
seems like his type of [__] also
I can't keep up with those cars
on the way to the restaurant I just I
just took the streets like I am not
trying to keep up with these fools they
oh one of these guys had an exhaust and
I thought I was tripping I'm like was
that fire no it was rocket ship flame
shot out of the back of this man's car
when he did yeah
[Music]
melted one of the guys films
Porsche was too close behind him when he
revved it it melted the guy's film off
his front of his Porsche oh my god when
I got to the house they were talking I'm
like What's Happening he's like he's
like well I mean like I think you melted
it man and like oh and they're going how
who's gonna pay what kind of car was a
sick ass Porsche in the front was a Audi
r8q something the one that's shooting
flames [__] Audi oh the Audi race car
one oh it's a okay Jesus those are sick
as hell but it had the exhaust and I
thought it was machine guns
we're waiting on the freeway and I heard
like oh and I got scared like what the
[__]
and I look and I go there's fire
shooting out of the guys like a
Batmobile
I like cars that [__] I've never seen
that's a liability
that's a lot put it this way someone's
trying to rob you you could burn their
leg off if they try to run it behind you
it was a rocket ship flame market like
my torch
this big around
good shots
Jesus like shotgun automatic shotgun
what is it that's making time I have no
flames and it melted like Porsches ppf
rap
uh anyway car guys they exist all right
I'm not one of them
I like cars though not one of them
anyway that's it we don't need them
shooting flames and [__]
dopest shop Lambo will be here in two
weeks what does that mean
John wrapped his entire Lambo the blue
one
suck
jet black
and we're gonna put the dopa shops
website and hella high club emblems on
it and we're just gonna park it
everywhere
it's a good idea people are gonna have
to come up and take a picture because
they love that car and then go what is
the dopest shot what is this QR code
it's fun
we'll take this the big plates off and
now you just have a car a black car
it's like a billboard it's like a
billboard
I don't know I think that was pretty
cool
enough about [__] enough about cars
I just wanted to talk about it I thought
it was the coolest thing ever
I put that car up on our Tick Tock just
yeah yeah just the engine just not even
revving it just idling that [__] sounds
scary I'm not a big car guy but I like
cars a lot
that's all
um yeah all right so that's what I did
that's my little story yeah that's
pretty [__] eventful it was fun okay
I know you got some [__] I know you got
some [__] lined up oh I mean
I'm just [__] glad to be back to be
honest I was gone for six days it felt
like at least two and a half to three
weeks uh
in my own mind I'm like uh I'm a two to
three day kind of guy I know leave it in
the comments it's a normal trip to
people
if you're going on a trip is it but not
normal people own all their own
businesses yeah okay when you're like I
got four days off I don't have to be at
work till Monday yeah and you're like
boom no work mode but when you're always
Your Own Boss you're like
four days could mean they hire somebody
else yeah
I'm not gonna wait you know like it's
different it's different when you when
you know you have those days off and you
don't own the business you're like bro
I'm not doing it because you just have
to rearrange the time and like all right
I'm gonna get this [__] done here then
and this done here then and that done
here then instead like
so that's why yeah ever since I I got
back I've just been it's crazy if you
think about it yeah
people like I wish I had time I have a
nine to five I can't don't have time
you have less time when you own your own
businesses
you know how hard it is to go to the
bank
like oh you don't have to go to work you
have to be a [__] I am work
it's isn't that weird like you figure
you have more time you're not nine to
five but it's like no no it's nine to
nine yeah
all that little [__] is irrelevant piles
up yeah it all piles up to a [__] a
four day event where you have to do it
all in four days yeah it's impossible
because you like no I can't sacrifice
that time nine to fives you're like dude
I'll do it on the weekend
play the weekend weekend might as well
be Monday
it's kind of weird when you think about
that yeah yeah so that's why your brain
does that yeah you're not ready to go
yeah I would never take you know a six
seven day trip just on my own like
people do that's a long time but also
it's like there's nothing for me you
know to really go back to it's like she
April's got family there my kids get to
have the whole family experience which
is nice and [__] but you know it's not
that's just not
it's weird for me you know I'm like kind
of tag along and follow around with her
Buffalo experience when I go back for
the most part now because I'm you know
kind of out of their mom's house and
[__] but anyway I thought it was funny I
knew I was like you know your Buffalo
and you [__] first thing you get out
of the airport and the dude not only
hits you up for a cigarette hits you up
in a way like that he's expecting you to
have one and then it's pissed off when
you don't yeah those guys are cool yeah
I was like damn you don't get that no
see they will shun you if they see you
smoking a [__] cigarette I saw a
young person smoking a cigarette the
other day is the first time I've seen
that in a long time it's weird to see
out here
not some not in Buffalo it's still very
much part of the culture
yeah isn't that odd used to be weird
first thing as soon as I got to the
airport I'm like that's hilarious
anywhere you filmed the wedding yeah
yeah so yeah I filmed the wedding which
was fun uh filming weddings is easy like
that's a good thing about thank you I
got one of these over here for you guys
uh it's a good thing about learning the
camera is that you can do so many
different types of things now like
people that film weddings are getting
upwards of like tens of thousands of
dollars to go and film the wedding in a
lot of instances pretty sure yeah and
it's the same as it's the same as any
other thing you film really like it
wasn't really that hard I was had a
really good time got a lot of good
photos everything went well and then uh
yeah I went back to my Mazel
neighborhood we parked took a little
picture in front of the house that was
really strange oh yeah it felt weird
you know just like not only because 10
years had passed and it was like the
anniversary of that and just felt good
about it but just things being so
different now and [__] was it was a
really really weird feeling
but uh it's cool seeing my kids running
around and [__] out there
but then um yeah the last day I was
there I actually got to go back and
chill with one of my boys and [__] and
actually like do my own thing because
like I'm April's mods house is like 40
minutes outside of the city I mean so oh
God I don't got a car I'm out there
you're just the boyfriend that lives
there for a couple of the job and [__]
yeah I know I'm just got all the kids
and [__]
but uh yeah I went and saw my boy
Wheatie and I I told him on the way
there yeah
yeah that's really like his teachers in
school [__] called him weedy and [__]
that's just been his name this whole
thing my name is weedy
and uh
he's definitely very deep in the uh in
the world out there
you know like
so it was I was like I'm I was gonna
last time I was there I took some photos
of him and there's something you guys
know me yeah yeah oh okay yeah yeah the
big dude yeah yeah it's some of my
favorite photos of all time like really
really dramatic sideways on the offense
yeah on the fans with just in right in
that area is right where we used to hang
out so
I mean for years like so many memories
over there and uh just going back over
there and [__] and I told him like let's
shoot a video instead of just you know
why not I'm like give me three pick all
three little locations I'm gonna get
three angles at each one and I'll do the
rest don't even worry about it and he so
he had to like be kind of be on the spot
like okay I'm gonna pick out a verse
because he's just coming home from work
or whatever and uh so then yeah when he
got there I was like we went uh he had
the Cadillac truck and [__] we went and
pulled up on the little side street
around the corner
I just started doing my thing this is
the fun part of being a video this was
one that was like I haven't had fun like
this in a long time because we're kind
of riding around and [__]
and uh just seeing all the streets over
there seeing it from the just this
perspective of myself now knowing that
you don't live there yeah it's real it
was so weird but also it's the exact
same
and it's like this is exactly what we
used to do we used to film these little
Run and Gun music videos and show it so
uh
yeah we just started going in I hopped
out started getting b-roll
one spot in front of the car we went
around to the uh little corner store
couple shots in the store outside of the
store
they were looking at me a little crazy
it's been a long time since I was over
there
you know like it's it's one of those
things yeah old dude's like
get shot over here with that camera a
lot of people on the low from the feds
over here gotta be careful with that
camera I'm like if you only knew the
half oh
[__] like that
but it was all good and then we uh yeah
we got a bunch more shots real nice
photos and then we just sat and talked
about just all this [__] and like just
the weed and what it's about to be in
New York all the areas opportunity
all my advice I could just try to
download
uh and it was great man it was fun it
was just weird like you know like uh the
little footage we put in the Spotify
video like looking at [__] like that old
like bro we were kids you think you're
an adult when you're like 20 but in
reality you're still a kid yeah we're
just now barely hitting adulthood you
know at this age I feel like but it's
like damn we didn't realize we were kids
back then we were [__] kids I think
about that all the time then think of
I hope you're not doing the [__] I was
doing
I was selling packs I can imagine
someone my age that age like having that
responsibility but I can
but like you always say I can't imagine
camera now here you always say [__] like
that oh yeah that's man that's like it's
normal if you're from over there and you
grew up over there it's normal but like
it's a heavy thing in the air you can
feel just going over there after having
not been there for a while it's like
there's there's tension man it's the the
tone in the air I don't know it just
fell
the whole the whole town like it's like
that that gray cloud was definitely
it's definitely there it just feels like
ominous I don't know it's just a lot
more a lot more empty a lot more
buildings are gone a lot more are
boarded a lot more uh it was just like
even like Ma's neighborhood it's just
like kind of
I don't know it feels emptier and
smaller Everything feels very like
scaled down from here I'm like a smaller
level in Chuck
but I already filmed I already edited
this quick little music video so I'm
thinking maybe we'll drop it in the uh
in our next Spotify playlist so we'll
see but hold on I gotta here let me let
me pull it up real quick
all I got from Buffalo was Marty
FaceTime and he goes this is the bridge
you go what bridge goes the bridge that
white people don't cross he's like once
they go over this person gets scared
like so so you're going to push what do
y'all love [__] the hardest all right
this is
oh that's what's going on
you edit this already yeah it looks
great already
shift
[Music]
yeah we outside
huh yeah I could never fold on the Bros
that's the code getting to be so
[__] natto club drop the load
now we got it for the low all about the
dough we're hustle in the snow crossover
then I hit him with the steps that
talking from the sideline I can't even
sweat that this is my revenge too I'm
plotting on my get back floating through
the lane but that [__] getting [__] yeah
we outside smoking awesome
[Music]
yeah we outside
that was about 15 minutes worth of foot
that was like maybe a little bit longer
than that really yeah I was just having
fun easy and that [__] came out sick
a wedding and a music video
yeah yeah I mean they stared at a window
I'm in there editing bongs editing
weddings editing [__] rap music
videos and [__] it was a good trip I
guess it sounds fun yeah
but uh
yes that's my word really the guy to
share we're gonna uh
it's just kind of in line with our whole
Spotify week we're dropping [__] like
this reacting to it check out the video
when should we drop that
probably Wednesday
a little bit after this video drops
Monday two more days will drop it
uh
so
I don't know if I've whined about this
on here or not I don't know if I want to
go
they're they're giving the bills a new
stadium yes you have talked about it
okay because it's just outside of
Buffalo though well it's just really
annoying me because it's like 12 000
less seats
smaller
okay
what it's directly adjacent next door to
where the car oh you said and it's still
open and there's no roof on it still
and they're like starting to post about
it I'm already feeling iffy about the
bills this season a little bit but
they're starting to post about this
goddamn new stadium and I want to get
excited for it but it's like
if you're not going to put it downtown
why not just put a goddamn roof on the
existing Stadium yeah update it a little
bit
what are we doing with this billions of
dollars here building this new stadium
with no roof when we cannot have a Super
Bowl you're punishing the [__]
players there's no way an advantage I'm
looking for I just want somebody to make
sense out of this [__] I commented
nothing makes sense I commented all this
on their [__] I never comment [__] on
Instagram yeah
and uh yeah I feel like I don't
understand something it seems really
wonky and like a dumb idea but uh it's
burning good anybody got any if I'm
missing something maybe you're
definitely not missing anything if it
doesn't make sense it's probably just
that [__] I notice a lot of things I
went hard on YouTube on I was on Twitter
since you can't just talk to YouTube on
YouTube I went on Twitter went hard on
awesome because it's like
there's just a point where I'm like you
guys are [__] with me so hard I don't
know what to do
anyway we won't talk about it too much
but
one thing I did do I went to Merced this
week
my cousin opened her store
Body Sculpting it's on G Street the body
art the sculpting Spa I think it's a
sculpting Spa sorry there's so many I
couldn't remember anyway she opened her
store congratulations that was super
sick right there in Merced reason I'm
bringing it up the second I get to
Merced
the second I drive in to to go to my
sister my uh cousin's door opening
I'm driving and obviously oh tweaker
two seconds ago it goes oh that sucks
watch them Bike by
I saw this phone oh you're hanging out
with you a lot oh
damn
I just saw sauce
and I was like damn oh my God I'm not
gonna say his name but
I used to hang out with that guy he's in
a story time or two
yeah he's gone
he's gone
he looks 60. what percentage of your
friends would you say are in a situation
where they have been or are currently
kind of tweaked out um or like let's
just say kids you graduate went to high
school with oh that's that that number
is not fair just people I know let's
just do people I know personally that I
would consider my friends
how about this Jeeves is good Anthony's
good
Deuce is good
Steve's good
so that means one two
three
seventy percent of my homies are outside
it's [__] up after that song that just
pledge we outside
oh
it's cold out there we can live all year
round that's a funny like same word
different meanings guys outside no no I
mean like we live outside damn
permanently it's crazy bro because you
know what's you know what sucks I'm not
gonna bring in names but my cousin my
uncle Carlos sends me Merced Sun star
arrest records sometimes like yo check
it out like damn
you know pools you grew up with or [__]
but he sends me a particular friend one
of my homies often
and it's like watching those [__]
Faces of Meth
picture slides would be like this
19.99
2000 2004.
2006 and then like 2010 they're monsters
you ever seen those pictures yeah
bro one of my homies my good friends
my uncle Carl sent me like three
different pictures over the course of
like the three months
and the last one you sent me last week
my homie looks at 60.
there
bro
I showed my sister the picture and she
just went oh and my sister's a dick and
she don't give a [__] even she was like
oh
dude look at that almost shot a [__]
tear when I saw the picture
I saw the patient who's it like no bro
oh my God you look like the dudes we
used to avoid
you know nothing about that do you feel
like the next generation of Merced is as
[__] up no that's good I would think
pills more pills and depression than
living outside tweaking okay I stopped
in Bakersfield yesterday
holy [__]
I've seen a lot of tweakers every one of
these Tweakers was under 20.
all Mexican dudes all pilled out every
one of them pulled out junkie Young
all were so [__] young
that's crazy
they couldn't be more than 22 or 20
years old maybe
but yeah
um I'll go send me the uh
shift remember said Sunstar I saw the
picture like
you look older my dad
wow
you are my age like we used to hang out
every day
weird and like of people that get like
that
I forget what Doctor Drew said can
recover back to life do present they're
always gonna have to be good tendencies
sorry
you'll never not have tweaker Tendencies
bro
and uh anyway yeah I told him Merced and
went oh [__]
no I know Rosie knows the guy too I go
that she goes she'll look look look she
was black go that is and I said the name
she goes [__]
well been here for 40 seconds
crazy
drove took a left to go by my old
apartments on K Street closed down
and I just went to the my cousin's store
opening she got like three uh Latin
awards for the geta California and [__]
because you know Hispanic Awards and
[__] it was pretty sick dude this
[__] City game gave her the scissors
to cut her show it's cool oh nice very
cool she's doing a good job
and then I immediately left I stayed in
town for an hour and left that's cool
yeah I just I had to go to your store
opening I cannot come on and now it's
awesome open a store yeah good [__]
[__] dude Body Sculpting in Merced and
she crushed it she does a lot of it's
Merced you do all this good job so yeah
so you're going back what is it July 8th
oh July 8th this this Saturday
if you are in Merced this Saturday July
8th I will be in Merced California shout
out to GB we've had him on the show
before we said we're going to do more
give back [__] because I was like can I
get involved
this is me getting involved finally I
got to do something and and pitch in and
do something and sponsor it um
it's basically
a concert La Russell Russell's
performing we had him on the show The
Russell's going to perform a bunch of
other Bay Area artists will be
performing
um there's gonna be free haircuts for
kids a bunch of sponsors a bunch of
booths a bunch of vendors
music obviously the stage is gonna be
the push tree stage sponsor the stage
the Russell just went went completely
bald no you
yeah
he looks like not the same version
it looks like
a different guy ten years younger yeah
he was a little boy
um oh oh to get in to get into the event
you have to bring one brand new toy
there's no tickets you have to bring a
new toy don't go to your kid's thing and
pick out an old toy you have to get a
brand new toy for the valley I think
it's the Valley Children's Hospital
or the Fresno children's hospital I
can't remember it's called give back at
the park all right this park is the park
from story time from all my football
practices across the street from where
my grandpa almost stabbed that man with
or cut him open with a machete across
the street from my dad's Apartments
where I found him all twacked out that
one time and drove off and all the story
times this is McNamara Park okay
the apartment's touching the park or my
grandma's Apartments
so if you've ever said those apartments
right there the cold that Triplex that's
my grandma's [__] so I've been there
every two months as a kid painting the
walls when people move I have I have
cleaned that yard a thousand times I
have painted that house those houses a
hundred times
and now it's so cool I used to I used to
pull my practice here now we're going
back to do this which is awesome and
it's a Valley Children's Hospital all
processed Valley Children's Hospital
every single thing is going to the
Valley Children's Hospital shout out to
GB and his homies for putting this on
come on
that is awesome how cool is that I'm on
the flyer and you know what he told me
goes you know how long it took me to
find a picture without weed in it
because he's like so I took that one
that one my hands like I have weed in
them nle episode yeah it is the nle
episode I have a joint in my hand on
that one oh no I don't have a joint
that's why he found it
but that's the same day that we've
filmed other people that's almost
thinking how to join my hand yeah that's
the nle day
um yeah that's really cool if they're
doing that and it's not even Christmas
like they're just doing that just doing
free haircuts for kids
no gang attire
no gang attire will be allowed you will
not be able to come in all right just
like school you can't wear gang colors
all right for every fan out there July
8th this Saturday Merced California 1040
Canal Street McNamara Park come through
be positive bring some toys for kids and
be a good person all right that's all
this is about I will be boxing my car
I'm not gonna be sitting there smoking
weed around a bunch of children so I
will be hot boxing my car
um
yeah oh
here we go now we're on the Merced topic
let's go a little story a little story a
little story here we go
as you guys know
um I may have mentioned it I'm from
Merced California all right I may have
mentioned this before
so I want to buy some property buying a
house in La is six times more expensive
than buying a house in Merced
some of the houses are set on the baller
side of the town like the most baller
sides of town the [__] I used to deliver
me-n-eds and go how the hell did you
have this house those houses
those houses are or a 12th of the houses
that out here you know what I mean like
the mortgage is a a an eighth of the
rent I pay now it's like dude that means
I can do it I can finally do it so I
want to get a house in Merced like I
told you I want to buy my grandma's
house
um
Ember said so I can have property and
start building property because it's the
only thing that's valuable like I'm
probably gonna take this watch back and
go put the down payment on the house
because I like the watch I'd rather have
a down payment on the house
or maybe I'll keep it I don't know
you know what I'm saying I'm trying to
be smart
so I started going through Zillow and
all that found a house I really like on
Alexander Street if you know where
that's at Mercedes it's in the nicer
side of town
so I'm I find a nice house the prices
around where I was thinking
I'm looking at the house I'm like huh
the house looks so familiar
all right going through the pictures
going through the pictures like
now this house is familiar and as a
pizza guy and I have a memory every time
something started with 19 1960 1918 I
can always remember it easier because
it's like a years
you know what I mean like 1840. I wasn't
alive back then 1970 like it's easier
for me to remember those addresses when
I was delivering pizza and I always
remember the address 1975. why because
it was my old connect John that
disappeared that was his first house
the house he bought at 18 19 years old
remember I said he has his own house
he's got a Mercedes this fool was
remember I said that on the story time
my dealers
this is the house
so I see it on Zillow I'm looking at I
go that is John's house
oh my God and I'm gonna tell you a
little story real quick the first time I
ever delivered a pizza to John I almost
said I almost say his real name all the
time
because it's so natural but his fake
name is John
I knew of him I've seen him a few times
because he's Ryan and Ethan's older
brother and we all know him like he's
the guy
he's the weed dealer of town he's the
coolest [__] out here he's the
guy you know I mean like that's the
[__] dude
so
go to my pizza you know I was like going
just have Me and Ed's I'm selling my
little packs here and there I'm Zone
pack selling sags doing my [__] he's the
connect he's the guy you need to know so
he opens the door I knock on the door
this is me and Edge right I'm 19 at the
time maybe 20 years old maybe 20 years
old
he opens the door in summer in the
summer time in Merced which means over
95 to 120. that's the range of Summer
right
115 120.
the man opens the door blonde hair opens
the door with no shirt wearing a fur
coat
a fur coat
no shirt
and I go
hey you're Ryan and Ethan's brother
right he goes oh yeah man yeah yeah
memory man oh for sure man here you go
man blah blah you tip me I'm like oh
good and I see you around well I know
like nine to 12 months later he'd be my
connect people chilling every day
hanging out become my [__] homie but
that's the first time I ever saw him at
that house and that's the house he
bought the house where I said he chased
his homie out and tried to kill him when
he knows his friend he just thought
someone's breaking in this is the house
the house the shootout happened this is
the house for sale
foreign
Jesus Christ so I'm trying to buy it
I'm trying to buy his house that's how
the realtor all that [__] get a discount
I try to say what happens if cash but
they do it cheaper if I just bought the
whole thing at once instead of doing the
mortgage and they go somebody already
offered that and offered it more and go
oh God somebody's selling man
um yeah I'm trying to buy a house in
Merced
and that's the house and then I I'll say
it again I mean I'll repeat I'll say it
but I'm not kidding it they told me they
told me that the offer is done somebody
already got it yeah but it was really
cool going
this is John's house it's the house I
met him at
13 years later I'm trying to buy this
[__] good [__] it's really
confusing with actual John being in the
equation now yeah John okay John from my
dealers let's just we I mean it's hard
to search his name up because so many
millions of people have watched that
episode and they know his name is John
his real name starts at the C we can
call him C
no because that's John's name John from
the dope his last name starts at the C
his name is John C
can't do this
the dopest John
then my uncle John and then John that's
why I always say John the dealer yeah
we should have had John here to [__]
straighten all this [__] out today he's
a little [__]
scared ass girl
anyway
yeah I tried to buy that
didn't work out
now the D.A of Merced he moved
there's a one strip in Merced that is
like some Mansions it's an odd little
part right by McKee he's moving it's 8
200 square feet damn
8 200 square feets on two and a half
acres it's got a pool a tennis court a
basketball court
everything you can think of
can you bleep the noise I'm about to say
yeah
that's how much they want for that place
it's just a regular home price and a
regular price
that in LA
15 million mm-hmm
yeah
so that's not fair
I wish Merced was I wish I could do what
I do in December said and go I would go
buy that place
right now and just buy it so hey I'm
gonna buy this today thank you get out
give me the keys and get out this is the
DA's house some of my friends away uh
now I live here
yeah it's actually your wife in this
room a hot box in this room now this is
where you had your kids oh that's why I
smoke weed now
the old DA's house huh that's how I feel
it
let me grind some nugs in here yep we'll
[__] put meth on the walls
yeah anyway I've tried to buy as a
property so you're still looking despite
the house that you wanted or not yeah
it's okay I'll think about trying to buy
the push tree's house but it comes with
two properties so it might be expensive
yeah like because I want to buy a house
to live in too so I'm gonna try to spend
all my money on the house just Amber
says an investment
maybe it's probably not going to be a
house that's like sentimental and [__]
it's going to be like some random house
you're going to finding I want to do a
Sentimental I want I want
my first house I want to buy is either
gonna be push trees my grandma's
something gotcha that'd be cool
okay sorry
that was the story I can't believe it's
his house insane Tweakers we've been
having a lot of like weird ironic
coincidences
yeah a lot I have actually randomly I've
been a lot of
paths Crossing lately you have the the
English lady last week's episode right
oh yeah it was last week
um okay I'm ranted enough can we get
into your notes
well on my way back flying Delta
oh yeah you called me I'm flying back
and one of the first things I see when I
land like as I get like service back on
my phone and [__]
Delta flight landed without nose gear
safely
I got a lot of thoughts on this so like
simultaneously to when I was flying
Delta this Delta plane uh from going
into Charlotte
how did it make an emergency landing
without the [__] front wheel
do they get raises
or do you is that like Hazard pay
for the stress of having to do that yeah
do the pilots get Hazard pay when like
yo your plane almost killed me
give me some money pay me more
but what's the most shocking thing to me
well on that same point too like what do
you give to your passengers oh you want
a free flight no I'm ever flying again
in my life [__] I need to check for
this yeah KRS one only but I'll leave uh
ships stay all these ships
goes in boats
it gets a little cargo boxes
write the lyrics to the wall
this one only ships
he doesn't fly but if he's in a box he
will ship him he feels like a stowaway
that means
um
the front of this plane is not
tore up from what you see like because
that's a ball and ass pilot he landed or
she
planted that plane so you're coming down
your back wheels down now your front
slams and it's on fire and it's like
shooting everywhere
but it looks pretty good though it looks
pretty good it does that's just probably
a picture from someone else it could be
before they took off oh
last episode real quick coincidence and
weird
we filmed the episode next day I went to
Merced we talked about my old neighbor
oh hey man Mr Edwards right I remember
his daughter Loretta Beach Nut and
Willie and all those people it's a great
episode
[Music]
standing at my cousin's [__]
store opening I'm standing there and
what did I talk about I needed to start
talking more go up to I need to start
conversating I went so I think in my
head goes I haven't seen that woman so I
was a kid I just talked about him holy
[__] talked about her yesterday on a
podcast don't say anything to her and
pretend that you didn't see her that's
what my brain said and I went no no you
just said you were gonna start talking
and doing more [__] who cares since I
went up and talked to her nice yeah I
talked for like 20 minutes Mr Edwards
passed away two years ago okay did not
know Willie the guy that oh the tweaker
crackhead uh sorry but Willie was a
crackhead
the one that I used to talk to all the
time the story time that he would always
ask you for wild [__] and then asked me
to heat up meat in the microwave at two
in the morning in some tinfoil
sounds that's Willy he just passed away
too remember that one time
where I said uh
Willie's homie a crackhead fixed my
whole car for like six bucks he fixed my
whole transmission or no my whole axle
took it off and everything
mm-hmm
um yeah Loretta I saw her that's who I'm
talking about her husband passed away
too the house that burned down on the
corner I talked about in the story time
that was her house she brought that up
it was crazy bro she's I'm like yo Emily
she goes
oh you you're the kid I'm like yeah I'm
I'm the kid man it's like why are you
here I was my cousin's story this is
your oh she was there for the store
opening it's like a women's not women's
but it's like a body sculpting teeth
whitening a bunch of different stuff so
she was there I just it was a shot they
lure in the housewives like April yes
shock to me I couldn't believe and I
told her yesterday I was actually
talking about you yesterday she goes no
you work
I was until I was on a show talking
about her but literally like I didn't
tell her that a lot of people know yeah
but I was like I was actually talking
about you with a friend yesterday that's
what I told her she's like no way I hope
everybody's doing good I'm like yeah my
grandma passed away he's like oh
like oh [__] like you know that was our
neighbor for 30 almost 40 Years of my
family Jesus that's a long time to be
neighbors man
especially in Old School ghetto houses
where it's
I'm on your hop I'm on your property now
oh but I'm still in my living room I can
just reach into your property now like
we could hold arms out of our bedroom
windows those old school houses you know
dorms damn near like a dorm anyway yeah
I saw her what are the odds
I don't know insane
but real quick can I can I say some [__]
I probably shouldn't say on the show
because it's probably gonna draw cause
some drama okay but my grandma
he's my uncle's new wife so much
and she's so nice to me and Rosie
then it's like Grandma
I'm not gonna be rude to her
but if I say hello to this woman in
front of my grandma my grandma is gonna
start spinning as fast as she can and
turn into a flame and strike me why does
she not like her so bad my grandma hates
my uncle's wife so violently my
grandmother cool one okay Grandma Grace
the really awesome one yeah sorry the
reason I bring it up because I brought
oh last week I got my little sisters
down for the first time in my life I've
never been able to have them by myself
oh they came down and chilled since
you're turning 18 my other sister's 16.
just by like
Quint like they just never I was gonna
go get him she just graduated high
school and say come down for like a
couple days come hang out say I'm 18 now
I can come down because like their mom
because I smoke weed you know they're
touching my dad's wife she's not too
fond of me
I don't think I've ever talked about
that but uh she doesn't really like me
which is insane and I'm like yeah come
get him so as I was going to get her the
same day I went to my my cousin's store
opening I went to pick up my sister and
my nephew uh Rosie's sister's son
and as I was picking her up she's like
can he become my other sister I'm like
yeah I thought you I thought you didn't
want her to come that's why you never
asked I thought it was like your trip so
I didn't want to like bring your sisters
like
I wanted to come you know I don't want
to do that to her if that was the case
but she's like no I'll bring her and my
dad's wife and my little brother in
Mexico right now so it's just my dad so
I was like
should we leave my dad by himself guys I
was like you know he's doing good he's
sober
should we leave him alone like
also this is a good test and you can't
just live your life hoping not to live
by himself guys let's go
so at the store thing that's why I
brought it up at the store thing I'm
like Dad I'm about to go pick up the
girls and he goes yeah I know I know I'm
like you're gonna be by yourself dude if
you want you get bored come on down
this is the reason I brought this up
okay if you're bored come on down
two seconds later my uncle's new wife
goes I get bored
we're bored we can come on down
and I was like in my head I'm going
you're so nice and super polite like why
wouldn't I say yes and the other head is
going Grandma will kill you
you know what I mean I'm like
I tiptoe the line of like you're both
what do I do like you're so nice you're
my uncle's wife you've never been mean
to me ever he's been with this lady for
15 years does she have a good reason not
to like her I'm not gonna put that one
out there my grandma my grandma her
do this and I don't give a [__] my
grandma wins I don't give a [__] even if
she's wrong that's my Grandma she's
awesome I'm gonna she I'm
till the wheels fall off I think that's
fair to expect you to hold the Vendetta
though a hundred percent that's why I'm
always playing I will never do that to
somebody they did nothing wrong to me I
don't give a [__] if it was Rosie
if Rosie didn't I'm still not being mean
to this person just because you don't
like I would never [__] do that
but as she said that I get bored I'm
like
I just get over invitation I have an
open house I just said it what do I say
I she heard everything sure and then I
saw my grandma standing all the way over
there because because she was over here
my Grandma will stand on the opposite
side of a building if that woman is in
the room damn
yeah that's good old school old school
Mexican hate
that's Irish I'm not gonna put out the
all their information because it's a
long story on why they don't like each
other it's actually very no telenovela
style it's very Mexican soap opera it's
actually the epitome description
definition of Mexican soap opera oh my
uncle's wife is a white blonde woman
sorry let me just throw that out there
all right she is not
Hispanic okay my grandma doesn't care
but now that she hates her oh she'll
throw that [__] on there too oh [__]
throw that [__] on top of it like she
always does this and then she just wants
to see him flip it she doesn't even flip
her hair but she just does that when she
thinks stupid dumb pretty [__] this is
my Grandma I love my grandma she's so
[__] cool she's the nicest woman and
when she starts talking [__] about
something she hates I'm like
you don't like her at all sorry that's
the reason I bring it up off track
but yes I told my dad to come down and
she just went huh so I
do so what did you do in the moment
yeah
let my uncle yeah whenever you guys
whenever you guys want you let you let
me know
and I went it is zigzagged out of there
because I'm like
I have no reason to tell you no you're
awesome to me
so are you just gonna have that
conversation with your grandmother then
100 chill out as far as I go
yeah I was hit Dr grandma what do you
want to do
it's Uncle I'm like damn it's my uncle's
wife
you want me to do I can tell my uncle no
the wedding you think I'm not inviting
my uncle to the wedding just because you
don't like his wife
not gonna happen Grandma it's not cool
to do to people in their weddings oh
it's my grandma wouldn't she's not gonna
do that I'm just saying like
my grandma was mad
she's is this her only like lifelong
Vengeance she's holding or does she got
a bunch of them my uncle my grandma
hated my uncle's other wife oh
for good reasons okay my Grandma's not
hating on [__] for nothing gotcha
my grandma oh my my other my other
stepmom I mean my other step Aunt our
other aunt that's no longer my aunt yeah
yeah my grandma's got some reasons to
hate her
I know I try not to call her aunt
anymore because I don't consider her my
aunt anymore I feel really bad she's she
[__] with me my uncle's ex-wife she
[__] me heavy she's never done nothing
wrong to me she's always been so nice to
me she's just not a good person
she's a bad person I know and I've seen
it happen I'm like you're a bad person I
got older your kids grew up so you're
trying to be nice but do you think we
forgot who you are that's how I feel
you know what I'm saying yeah totally so
it's like
so there's not much you can really do
with that other than like thank you for
being nice to me I just don't want to
invite her to the wedding oh yeah you
gotta really like the wedding invite is
she's been there since before I was born
Ben where like in our family my uncle
got divorced from her like [__] 10
years ago oh she's my aunt since I was
born weddings are weird and that it is
very like Myspace top eight people are
in the wedding party they're at this
table or that table
everything is very like delineated it's
just
I don't know I just think it's wild it's
like damn girl
you hate her more than anybody I've ever
seen hmm
my grandma's awesome I'm like what I say
I'm not saying anything wrong but my
grandma my grandma has every right to be
[__] pissed but I didn't I wasn't
involved so I can't say anything sorry I
thought I'd bring that up that's how I
mean that type of family drama really
happens though
oh I'm over here smoking weed in my
house I could care less that's why I'm
like oh that's what's going on oh crazy
oh nuts
yeah but I'm already on this like
Grapevine as you were talking [__] about
somebody else I'm gonna leave yeah
I don't have enough time for that I
could do other things with my time did
you get any cracked windshields any sort
of defects anything horrible happen this
trip I'm bringing the May back down next
week
for the only time okay
all right
it's been a couple good runs well I
haven't brought me back anywhere
but I'm just saying like you went ahead
of stretch where you went like three or
four times in a row some [__] happened
oh yeah yeah now we're chilling
I got a rental I've been getting uh
shout out to Enterprise shout out to
Enterprise man
all right I rent cars I don't bring the
cars to Merced anymore that's smart it's
too many it's just too many miles
yeah it's cheaper to rent a car
um okay on to these notes and before we
get on to these notes I'm let's talk
about this real quick I got all my push
tree samples for the first half of the
drop so sick everything looks great this
is one of them this is completely puff
print
I'm wearing push tree slides right now
Game Changer that are actually dope
they're not stiff as a board [__]
slide You by for a dollar they're great
they're [__] awesome
we are dropping
five shirts in this first trap not one
of them is a black shirt
there's not one black shirt and anything
well hold on I'm gonna bring this up oh
I'll hit this right now though sorry
nothing but color
blue brown beige cream
it's really cool it's really cool
the reason I'm bringing this up is
we got our samples we're gonna drop in
about two weeks
photo shoot next week right
but besides that the next drop is a
three weeks after that jackets pants
shorts skateboards
um
sweaters with Pat like the patches
instead of pictures I don't think I've
seen this wave yet oh I'm very excited
dude I'm really really this is the first
person to use jackets ever yeah wow yeah
like this is uh
we're going to a whole different level
of things I'm very excited super stoked
and besides that
these will be dropping hopefully no no
these will be dropping the week of this
video comes out
[Music]
as you can see push trees bunks all
right sandblasting here sandblasting in
the bottom Story Time orange so sir
shout out to Jay super smack Bros as I
was coming up with colors he's like do a
story time orange I'm like yeah why
don't I do a story time orange color on
the bong I always do other colors do a
story time orange so shout out to Jay
for suggesting it because it looks good
it looks really good and uh yeah they
look incredible these are nine
millimeter I believe these are almost
10. I gotta be honest because we tried
to do that these are nine millimeter
thick made here in Anaheim made in the
exact same spot as Roar so don't be
eating talking [__] but like this shit's
not the great like it's in the same shop
[__] and two millimeters thicker than
the average Roar handmade in America
German glass all the glass comes from
Germany they don't make the glass they
all get it for the twos from Germany
gotcha so Jeremy glass so fools I just
knock off bro this is the most this is
the how you do it all right this is how
you get it done the right way this is
month five I've been waiting on these
wow month five all right Story Time
orange this is the 16 inch then we got
the see-through galaxy blue
12 inch right there same exact things
sandblast sandblast I know y'all you
guys are not watching you're listening
I'm just showing you some bongs and I'm
only bringing them all out because
they're all packed
we're gonna smoke all of it when you
guys see this push trees video we're
about to drop this [__] when it's cold
and crisp it's brand new looks like
just I don't even know like AI
yeah it did it looked like CGI shut up
look at this now the 16 inch version of
the blue
there it is that thing looks clean
is it
12 inch Story Time Story Time Orange
these are GTA bongs yeah this is what I
mean by Grand Theft Auto a perfect
little chugger Franklin has on his
counter or on his by his couch when you
go into the house to save
it's perfect oh a little news
well you know what maybe I shouldn't put
him on blast like that
never mind you'll find out when we find
out okay we'll be getting high soon here
we go
I think we talked about that in your new
video we might have
I don't I don't know yet so let's just
let's wait and then last but not least
the 12 inch rainbow
super sick ass almost zebra stripe gum
rainbow Stripes like this we've had the
rainbow before this is a better rainbow
version the other ones were uh thin
Stripes these are pinned like
thicker almost candy cane stripes
the shit's tight the shit's tight dude
the thumb on that one looks so sick that
that one looks the coolest when you look
down different patterns Epic Ice holders
and shirt epic so all these are coming
out this week they'll be out this week
posters.com quality for versus price
you'd put these up against anything in
the world
like if we're talking about a pound for
pound the way I say it like it it's got
two hits right it's got two hits
color lip color down stem
hit sandblast sandblast in the bottom
it's also nine millimeter
and made in America handmade in America
obviously it's on a lathe
chairman glass not China glass it's not
there's no shortcomings of this bong
everything is top quality
this if it said Roar this would be 280.
if this at Philadelphia
this would be 400. if this said Roar
this should be 320 which is Chill I mean
those are American made great bongs I'm
never gonna knock them they're great a
little expensive they are
for what it is if I could if I was going
to be a glass guy I could sell this for
250 just because it's American made all
the [__] you know high glass or uh
highly edgy or what is it called hi
something that thick ass bomb ass class
those are very expensive this is thicker
than those I'm not knocking anybody I'm
doing the American Gangster thing I'm
going to give you a better product and a
cheaper price and no it's not a [__]
fake
um
that's it it's Blue Magic
boom that's exactly the name of this
color now blue magic all right analogy
look at that that's what I'm trying to
do because
what happens when we get cheaper [__]
for the for push trees I don't charge
you more
but you know what I'm saying like and I
know it sounds crazy good cheap or
charge more if I sell you a share for
thirty dollars and I make it for 15 I
double up
right
what happens when I start getting that
shirt for ten dollars
I have dropped my prices before to 28
because I got a better deal on it and
why not pass the deal on to you guys I I
can make those two extra dollars or I
could probably sell more shirts because
you guys like damn cheaper shirt let me
get two shirts
that and the brand goes everywhere I'm
not worried about the two dollars more
than I am like you guys are so hyped and
you guys got a cheaper deal and you guys
are thinking damn 56 versus 60 I know
it's not a lot but if I bought five
shirts bro let's
it's money it comes you guys see it when
you're buying weed you see it when
you're buying anything so I figure if
you can get this bong You Follow Me you
like bongs do you like good glass do you
like good glass at a good price I
probably got a sale
but if you don't like me
and you see this bong everything about
it is good
me you liking me or having a following
should not make the sale
that in my head like if I didn't have
that could I still make that sale
and that's how I make things just based
on the product based on the product this
right here you don't have to know what
push trees is you could just like fun
looking trees or you could know that
this is some high-ass [__] I got two
versions of people people that don't
know people that do know or people that
just like the art
and then people that like good printing
that's the first art that doesn't have
any weed in it that's just art right our
whole drop has not weed in it hmm
but it's we adjacent yeah you know it's
like oh that's some that's some weed
[__]
I can't wait to show you guys the
artwork the artwork on this new job is
so [__] sick it looks so good
everything looks so [__] fun
I'm just excited Marty let's move on to
your notes I'm sorry we're over here
just rambling and one last thought on
this where are we out with push through
his cannabis push trees cannabis
companies probably gonna come out in the
later months of this year just because
we feel like we're just rushing things
we were gonna try to drop two months ago
and we thought
why drop and we're not fully prepared
like we need to be
you know those brand new restaurants you
go in you go you got like 15 different
items you got 40 workers just standing
there waiting to work that's what we
need to be when we drop our weed because
in three months that restaurant is just
doing good
you know what I mean but you go in there
brand new like oh oh [__] we didn't get
we out of cups we gotta go to Costco and
get cups just get the generic ones and
we'll just write it down keep the
receipt and we'll put it on our
inventory list for the end of those
people go under and they're on like Bar
Rescue and [__] like that
I don't want to be that I'm trying to
make a hundred million dollars yeah you
know I'm trying which is very feasible
I'll say it right now some of your
favorite Wii Brands last year made over
200 mil 250 ml Jesus Christ with no face
I'll never steer you wrong and that's
why that's why the show was so
successful four years ago yeah yeah it's
true I could have been making money off
some trash for years I could have put
these out in bought them downtown and
had somebody sandblasted downtown kind
of for 14 and sold them to you for a
hundred I could have done all that [__]
but I won't you have real experience now
too going into the push trees cannabis
thing with like and we have some backing
we have some not in terms of money we
have some bagging in terms of help
I can't say who or what they do I mean
who they work with but
they help run I think the second biggest
company in America
and they're going to help us with a lot
of logistics sir
um
fourth biggest
those same still yeah like really really
good weed companies I'm not talking
about like Pepsi that's not what I mean
like I'm talking about wheat companies
um
so guys real quick I'm gonna
move forward Marty you got some notes
which following you want to hit uh I'll
hit the blue one blue well let's just
say in this upcoming video you attempt
to in one abroad at once yes you gotta
come up with a name for that
baller
Immaculate incredible
James Brown
that's quite the challenge it's like up
there with the marathon it's hard yeah
you should do it all the time you used
to do five in a row and a ball and a dab
yeah everybody out there in the stoner
Olympics do you guys remember when I
used to smash on that [__] my lungs are
not what they used to be because I don't
practice no more hey man even if Kobe
stopped for three or four years he
probably wouldn't be able to hit that
[__] just right but I guarantee you give
them three weeks of practice he's
off your [__] face so
I'll be throwing bongs at your face soon
is what I'm saying here we go let's rip
this oh we got analogies for days
all right is he ready oh I'm so high
Marty
right I just did it again
mouth on the microphone ready
boom
that's a good one that's a good one
good shot all right leave it there I got
you
good shot
okay okay okay notes notes notes what
what we are here talking about
okay now I'll bring these back in a
second this seems like it's a pretty big
story today
thank you because
Elon Musk limiting the amount of tweets
people can see in an effort to fight
against what Bots and [__] like that
stop what do you mean like it cuts off
the amount of tweets you're allowed to
look at today
so he posted earlier to address extreme
levels of data scraping and system
manipulation verified accounts are
limited to reading 6 000 posts a day
they also think my real question is how
many posts do I look at a day like not
that many I mean
I I have no idea what the number is how
would you even [__] count that
every time I mean I'd be interested to
know how many times I kind of just
opened the apps of my phone and scroll
through them a day but if you put it at
6 000 posts a day
it seems like a lot
you know it's crazy
my brain's so OCD and weird I know how
many posts I look at
because I count them so I know I stop on
an even number wait what I'm scrolling
uh seven now let's go to eight you're
counting them
that's exhausting I'm not counting my
brains counting them so I'm keeping like
a little scoreboard over here while I'm
reading [__] of how many posts you've
been scrolling through only each time
gotcha one two three oh I clicked that
one oh that was sick okay that was four
I gotcha boom start over again
that's 12 12's even you're keeping place
on it's disgusting
okay as long as I end on even numbers in
my head since I was a kid it's so stupid
especially on YouTube when I'm scrolling
and then I hit a community post go
that's not a post I have to go again I
swear to God my [__] brain will do it
and I'm not even doing telling myself to
do it my brain just will do it go
oh
14. it's not stupid
like it never just lets it ride no it
never does oh it's really aggravating
damn right I swear to God I look like
I'm just chilling sometimes I'm counting
numbers of certain [__]
if you see me not talking it's because
I'm counting how many steps I've taken
bro I was in New York I was up to like
two something and I was like bro chill
relax
that's exhausting my brain can't do any
extra [__] we've talked about it when I
got when I started having OCD we talked
about it
maybe in season one or something
I always do things the same or I think
something might might happen
as a kid and I found out that's OCD that
only happened because I would do that
sometimes I would count by even numbers
as a kid okay
and then my Uncle John's Homie Chris got
killed at work
and the night before it happened I
always slept with a black Green Bay
beanie on my head to keep my hair out of
my face my hair was long I want to get
his I was breaking out I always wore it
back and I wore it back every night and
I put it in the same spot
and one night I threw it and it fell and
I went that's fine
and I was going to sleep I'm like let's
just get up and put in the spot
that's how my brain worked as a kid
let's just do it something might happen
like dude chill the [__] out if he'll
die the next day and I walk back home I
got home found out went in my room and
saw the beanie in the ground went you
tied the two like together in your mind
instantly went
[__]
was that my fault that's what my brain
did
whoa
no idea why that happened and ever since
then
it's been going like that [__]
yep ever since then
super stupid does it almost doesn't make
any sense yeah I mean no it doesn't it's
it doesn't actually make sense but the
brain still does it my brain does a
little weird [__] like that I know
April's does but I always do [__] go
just do it now because you know
something's bad's gonna happen just stop
I do that when I see like a bong on the
edge and I'll go bro just
yeah that makes sense right now yeah
that makes sense no with anything I'll
see something at the edge go what if
somebody Falls goes back that falls they
get up they're gonna hit their head on
that [__] let me just move this [__] I
always see a [__] is like Final
Destination like well that's like that's
like being cautious that's being a
cautious person versus the Hat has no
tie to the dude getting killed at all no
it's just me like bro I knew I should
just did this thing the same thing every
day so you're living in a world where
there's some psychotic
God that's like and my uncle John I was
like sit and I was like 10. we're
watching TV goes you gotta end on even
numbers oh he put the [__] in your place
like the TV will blow up like that's oh
he was I knew he was kidding okay that's
goofy that's dumb and I found myself
anything on even number and that's all
my sister do it the other day and I went
why do you do that because
oh my God John did that to you too this
is [__] I was watching Evil Dead one
when that [__] happened to me I was 10
living on Olive
watching Evil Dead one I don't know what
that is it's a movie with Bruce Campbell
and he came back in with his Homie Chris
I'll never forget that [__]
that's exhausting I'm glad that it is
exhausted it is exhausting it is that's
why we talked about the knocking on wood
[__] yeah oh all that extras
Christian [__]
the day I stopped doing that is the day
I become that fool from [__]
Independence Day was like I'll fly the
ship the plane into the thing and kill
and save Earth the day I stopped doing
this [__] is the day they're like yo
only you can do it and you're gonna die
because of it like [__]
I'm [__]
[__] I knew it
knew it you were right
at least I can walk off like that
Breakfast Club like
I was right and now you all know you
should have just knocked on the [__]
table yep I swear to God it's been
happening my whole life it's so stupid
so dumb
just or my brain like things I think
come true all the time so when I think
of bad [__] I'm always like oh no no no
no
yeah I'm like that too like I don't talk
about stuff I don't want to happen at
all no I don't but it comes in my brain
a lot I see pictures and little
screenshots all the time and so many
things have happened that I thought of
then I go bro be careful yeah uh it's
happened too many times
for me to go that's not real like oh no
it is
I've been there and it happened exactly
like that
that's all I just feel like we're in a
video game and then this level in my
brain I control a few more things than I
thought in my head so that's what OCD is
that's what it is OCD is when we were
being programmed and the computer in our
brain was like yo give this full slight
virus
sometimes
sometimes both
and they program it so when people are
crazy and going nuts I feel like they've
got a bad virus and have like spyware or
whatever hmm
pretty much what it is it basically is
basically what it is like a misfire if
this Matrix is real they're on the other
side and the guy that they plugged them
in they didn't like the guy and they
were like not give them a shitty time
give them a shitty time unplug one of
those fuses they're kind of like a
[__] up confusing experience yeah give
him a [__]
make him born in the 50s in America it's
going to be just a waste of time
basically overall he's not going to
really do it and then when you die and
come back and you take the goggles Lobby
like what's gonna be five more bucks
like whoa
hey the the world could be whatever it
is you never know what it is that's kind
of how I think about it not so cynical
and [__] up we're real I feel like
Avatar kind of nailed it Avatar kind of
nailed it
and I got real lucky
they're like it's gonna be real bad at
the beginning
it's gonna be real sick
just hang in there
and then one day you're gonna be driving
and then you're gonna get a call are you
gonna get a call from two guys from a
video game
gonna be real [__] crazy that's when
you're gonna know as you're gonna know
something's up
and you can fly
you could fly just [__] do it
that's the reason why Peter Pan was on
the morning he left that thing like it
was which was weird anyway
Earth life I like those moments yeah oh
yeah those moments to me are the
synchronicity moments where it's um
outlandish [__] that I'm like I'll be
listening to somebody and they'll say
the words and I'm just typing randomly
all the time that type of [__] is like
those type of moments where I'm just
like all right I'm just gonna keep doing
what I'm doing right yep love that deal
this is rant scene let's get into your
notes uh so
I didn't think this was true at first
but now that I see Dana White talking
about it oh you're talking about the
limited Post Yeah I was I'm kind of like
still now I'm talking about Elon uh
cause he's talking about fighting UFC
MMA fighting [__] Mark Zuckerberg oh
oh oh I thought it was a meme I thought
this was I didn't think that was like
anything within the realm of uh reality
I'm just but then
when I saw Dana White talking about it
and
I'm seeing them training and [__] this
is Marty I can I have the explanation
for you okay this explanation every
here's your clip here's your clip okay
for everyone out there that controls the
Earth some people have figured it out
don't hold it against them they don't
give a [__] I think I might have figured
it out please don't come for me don't
give a [__]
the two richest men on Earth want to
brawl the two richest men on Earth
want to have a physical combat bout
the world is now idiocracy it happened a
lot faster than they thought
the world is at play
and this show is only to distract us
from the other [__] up show that's
going on behind scenes because if the
two richest people on Earth want to have
a fight and people can view it I'm gonna
tell you right now those men have egos
both those men don't want to be punched
in the face in front of humans and go I
remember I got punched in front of the
face all the money in the world can
erase your memory
none of those guys want to be
embarrassed let you say that if Mark
Zuckerberg and Elon Musk got in a
fighter to murder that kid
Mark Zuckerberg have you ever seen this
the South Park
South Park you really nail it you really
nail it and that's the ultimate goal is
if this last episode of this show in
nine years time or 12 whatever the [__]
it is maybe it's 50. if we get Madison
and Trey Parker on here for this crazy
South Park to sit here and have us a
nine Hour episode that's the way to go
out
because they they really just Crush
everything the episode where they make
fun of Mark Zuckerberg my style
he's a fighter in that episode I didn't
see that
that's exactly how I think he would
fight in real life oh my style
oh you're what you get my style yo it's
such a good episode that's all he keeps
saying over and over and over oh so you
want to fight
but like an old like
70s movie style oh it's so stupid I'm
taking Elon Musk slash AKA Liam Neeson
I'm taking I'm taking Elon Musk he's
gonna do a full taken
thing on Mark Zuckerberg
he's five seven oh okay
Mark Zuckerberg is only five seven okay
Elon six one stop it he's five seven you
know I might really mop him if he like
were to you know what I mean scoop them
in body slam them or some [__] Mark
Zuckerberg looks so tall
on all the videos and every picture he
looks so tall
I pictured him kind of like maybe a
wrestler back in middle school or some
[__] he's five seven Elon Musk his head
is so big he can Crush that man with
just his upper body
I'm sorry I'm taking Elon Musk all the
way plus Mark Zuckerberg you don't [__]
with the weed and you keep denying and
[__] deleting all my [__] so you can
eat oh that's a fair point yeah no yeah
Twitter let me get high and [__] I [__]
with you Mark Zuckerberg you can just
suck a dick well not really just be
nicer to us yeah Facebook just monetize
this yeah Facebook just be nice to us
though man for the love of God God you
guys really hate on us
Jesus sorry
it's been a it's been a few weeks since
we've had a deletion last night
there you go I knew it was coming
yo
I'm taking Elon Musk let's go to the
next topic I'm sorry what is the next
topic they just released a new pair of
Jordans
I'm not a huge Rosie if you shut off a
picture of every Jordan Rosie could tell
you what number it is
she used to sell Jordans that's what she
used to do in high school I'm kind of
like that not so much they just don't
start
dog [__] to me Air Jordan 38s just
dropped it's been emitted since uh
they've had some new Jordans drop
so I didn't really know what to expect
I like spizzics
only joins I like I told you I swore off
Jordan I won't wear them no more I'm I'm
done watching my shoes get creased
I'm done watching the crease go oh it
used because they were so expensive and
now it's like some of the shoes I buy
I'm like
um
why was I worried about George and I
should be worried about these
[__] stupid ass shoes
I don't care I wear Vans every day right
now I'm wearing my own slides because
it's the first time I've had plush tree
shoes
so I have to wear that [__] that shit's
sick so sick so [__] cool it's been a
long ass time since I had some Jordans
too and I'm trying to think but like
yeah I'm not really in love with these I
mean drop into the chat drop it in the
comments oh that's what I was gonna say
because when I posted on uh Instagram
the other day when the bills and all the
shoes the bills and Nike did some sort
of weird collab where they had like
bills blue bills red on football Brown
and the [__] on a on an Air Max
and the [__] was like it would look so
sick if it was like light gray dark gray
white black basically Marty said it
would look so good if it was the colors
I like
the brown just to me I wasn't feeling it
looked like football texture yeah but
like Bill's colors this is so funny
Bill's colors you know [__] you know my
[__] just not that shoe basically say I
would design the shoe for you but only I
might like it well here's the
interesting thing I posted it on
Instagram the pole with a fire or a
trash bin and it was [__] 50 50.
which is just one of those things I
thought it was going to be a landslide
victory of people being like what the
[__] I don't want these brown shoes but
people like that [__] brown pride Marty
so you guys let us know
damn those Jordans
shout out to Michael Jordan being the
cause for
young uh kids getting robbed since 1985.
so uh
oh I watched that um that that Nike
it's on Netflix it's about when they air
sign yeah you watch the movie yeah she
was all right all right I have to watch
that [__] it was all right
all right I got a I got a horror story
for you
so
I walk into my garage about
[Music]
I don't know maybe two months ago and I
see my cat playing with something
and she's like I can't really uh tell
what it is
then I come to find it's a severed
lizard towel
so a lizard made its way into my [__]
garage
cat saw it stepped on his tail their leg
their tails detach from their body
and then I had to [__] chase down
this does it tell us lizard and catch
him and let him outside and it was
[__] mortifying all right it was
disgusting you could just imagine and
then I can imagine picking up me not I
mean I'm just walking into this
situation I'm horrified at the [__]
cat
picking up this twitching tell still
throw it out
and again today
I see the [__] cat that was like two
months ago because I'm in my garage the
doors got a little half inch Gap so
these [__] lizards are coming in
to this lion
she's batting at something underneath
the leg of my desk I slide the leg of
the desk out of the way [__]
twitching lizard tell
again I almost puked
imagine it's just sitting there and now
you gotta [__] go get a paper towel
and pick up a severed [__] tail again
this time no sign of the [__] lizard
though
I can't imagine
my mom Me growing up my mom had one pet
and that was iguanas
she looks like I could see her she used
to have a bunch of iguanas snakes
she used to [__] with Iguana's heavy
you know when I found out that lizard's
tails come off
about five years old you know who told
me me the wizard The Lizard we had a
connection you know why because his tail
ripped off and I [__] lost my mind
like iguana got out of the cage and I
was like trying to get it and I was
trying to scoop him but if they have
like little talons
and their Skin's weird and they have
like little stomachs and when they
breathe they're like so it's like you
can feel their little bodies
I was like I don't want to hurt you
and I was trying to get away and I
cracked I got it into the corner and I
as I was like [__] five and I'm like
this I'm like oh stop stopping like a
dog-sized iguana a big one no no it's
like probably this big
okay tail to head baby one
I'm like all right I'm on my knee like
okay stop
because if it's out it's my fault or my
sister's fall or because my mom was such
a mean [__] she could have left
it open it's our fault so I'm like no
I'm not getting
putting it back even though I didn't do
it I walked in the [__] was
running
peeling out and [__] I got no grip
and I'm like stopping stopping the fool
tries to go and I go like that I put my
hand on his tail just try to stop it and
it [__] came off
and the tail just went
as I stopped it and I noticed because it
kept running and that's when I noticed
the tail was still under my hand and I
[__] you ever see a Dragon Ball Z
when they go
they [__] power up that was pretty
much me I saw the tail and I went
no I [__] screamed I ripped my shirt
off did you feel disgusted scared
disgusted or scared confused sad
confused
did you want to puke or did you want to
throw up were you mainly scared you're
scared of my mom than anything oh
wow I went to my mom losing my mind oh
my gosh
no oh no no no no no the second I saw a
detached I like almost am I backed up
ran to my mom started screaming telling
her she's like it's okay it's okay it's
okay the tails come off and I was like
[__]
I like [__]
with Gary Coleman what you talking about
what the [__] are you trying to tell me
that their tails come off you're a
[__] liar that's all I thought yeah
and say Thomas they come off it'll grow
back and I was like if I was bigger I'd
smack you for lying you're gonna tell me
the [__] it's just gonna grow back
you're a damn liar you're gonna tell me
in all my life and everybody says [__]
doesn't grow back be careful you only
get one the lizards don't they they're
not that they only don't get one you're
a [__] liar mom
just like when you told me Shirley
Temple had passed away when I was a kid
and I come to find out she's on the late
night show with my grandma and I'm like
Shirley Temple she's dead like she's
like no she's not
[__] bad information mom
anyway that's why I was like I don't
trust you [__] lizards tails don't
get come back yeah right [__] and then
um grew back
for the next couple days I'm like lying
ass [__] there's a no you expected her
to freak out she's surprised me down
because I was freaking the [__] out I
was I heard it I was so scared
and I'm thinking like I heard it it's
hurt like yeah
and then
my mom put the lizard out
because they get in the Sun and she
forgot it and it died
right then like no no like weeks later
she she put it out in the sun you know
they sunbathe or whatever yeah I thought
that's like she got a phone call
and then she forgot about it for like an
hour went out it was dead an hour I'm
sad it's hot as [__] it was for a lizard
stiff as a board oh it just
oh I remember she picked it up I heard
it
oh it was so bad bro
it's that hot for a lizard to just it
was it couldn't go anywhere it was stuck
right there because it was in the little
cage it couldn't there was nothing for
it to go it was sad dude Jesus that was
very sad that [__] me up but she had
like [__] she got there was so many
different ones anyway yeah I know
lizard's Tales come on
oh my God that's how I found out now let
us know in the comments because I asked
the people on my Instagram and I was
surprised by the amount of people
do you
do you do most people want to throw up
and are like mortified at the idea of a
[__] twitching lizard tail or are you
just kind of like all right you just
pick it up and throw it out and you're
really not that freaked out about 99.9
people are going to be disgusted
that's what I thought too for sure
that's what I I mean that's that's a
hundred percent on my Instagram we're
acting like it wasn't that [__] big
of a deal yeah right I think the options
were like
get rid of the cat burn down the house
and run away or
just throw the towel out and it's not a
big deal no no no no none of that
disgusting
um
so it happened again lizard tail
lizard's tails are falling off
what is your next topic Marty we've been
here for 218 are you kidding me yeah
hey we've been here for a while holy
[__] last topic I got here is something
that I don't really know so much about
but I feel like it's really relevant to
at least one of our friends and a lot of
the people on the show which was the
passing of
[Music]
and a bunch of people in La that I know
were like tied into him in this brand
yeah so whenever people ask me about
clothing companies like what are the big
clothing companies I always say born and
raised StreetWise
if you're a la person those are the two
big Brands I think of I'm I'm not very I
don't know a lot of companies like the
Lakers is like
the LA brand to me I'm the outsider
looking in so remember this guys I'm not
from La I'm from Northern California
I don't know all the LA culture [__] I
mean I do know a lot of it now a lot of
my homies from L.A I've been living here
for seven eight years I get it
but when I came here born and raised
every fool was wearing it every four had
a sick ass embroidered born and raised
hoodie Omar ratchet man he's the one
that showed me born and raised like
that's when I started catching more
attention when he showed me it because
he had the sweaters on and the hat he
would always Rock the Hat
and um
just a sick brand honestly Marty just a
sick streetwear brand that's really what
it is very La culture very uh
local
I guess you would call it well I mean
yeah born and raised so yeah apparently
the the owner or the co-founder co-owner
passed away crazy [__] dude
the sad I said a car accident which is
really [__] up which is insane anybody
died in a car accident but let alone
someone doing so much [__] someone's
really crushing it for 20 years like
damn bro it's sad
that's really sad then I saw somebody's
a news article saying that his born and
raised times Nike collab comes out this
week
Jesus Christ of your life well you
passed away right before that's horrible
let's talk about that's he I was
inspired by that brand and just kind of
going back and looking at everything now
you know these past couple days and [__]
it was just
it's really sad to see so big shout out
to everybody that's affected by that and
his family and
everybody that's tapped in with that
brand and [__] I know it's a bunch of
our friends and people are online with
the show so
yeah a lot of people we know that being
on the show are exactly friends
man it's L.A like a lot of people were
the circles they know because you never
think like who owns that company you
don't just like the company at least I
don't I don't go who owns the company I
just think I'll stay close oh let me get
that shirt yeah yeah so you know there's
so much and plus it's not like he was 20
years old the fools like a grown ass man
been doing this for two decades
in the town all local Pride type of
thing and it's like damn fool that's sad
still on the rise it's bad that's bad
yeah it's terrible
but yeah I saw that as all ratchet man
posted too
um well yeah shout out to his family and
[__] that's sad terrible
um
but yeah damn we've been here for a
minute
you saw that yeah yeah it's two hours 22
minutes 22 seconds that was sick
um
yeah I think uh
I think that's pretty much everything I
we had to talk this is just like a
catch-up episode we're about to go on a
big run of guests about to go on a big
run of guests We're not gonna have one
of these episodes for a minute
so we just wanted to get here and talk
to you guys we have a lot of different
guests coming up
we're we're just
I talked to go Island about this
love Stevo love Tony Hawk love all those
guys
that's sure all you do
Superstars
when I talk to Goblin when after his
first episode I talked to him or the
second episode I'm like bro
do you realize like
your fans who care they're they're there
and I compared him to our fans like they
give a [__] about what you get what
you're talking about they care they they
know that you're a genuine human being
that's why he's like yeah bro I got
she's like dude after the podcast that's
like so much exposure to other [__] so
many people watch my channel and I was
like whatever you guys need it's like
I've been so he's so dope he's such a
nice guy Nick's great and um
it's the fact that it content creators
control the internet
it used to be like I my name is Lil
Wayne or would I take whatever huge
biggest biggest giant hi my name is
Kanye West
Connie is a different example he'll pull
a crowd anywhere damn it
biggest rapper of other biggest rapper
hey I'm gonna go on a show
400 000 views first day damn pool of
numbers people want to watch that's
great
bring a goblin in boom million views or
Eric or you bring in content creators in
the in that space
will dominate the internet
so when I say like we have a bunch of
different kind of guests we have
different kind of guests and like when
we left to go to the agency we're
thinking like okay we gotta get the
biggest stars in the world and we did
and you guys liked it
but you didn't give [__] because those
aren't the people that you're connecting
with every day
which is cool we can still have those
guests on that's great those guests
allow other guests to go oh they've had
them on at least am I gonna get robbed
when I get there oh all right I'll tell
my manager yes we'll do the show
it's kind of like a vouch a voucher
right
and I feel like dude look at that
content creators are Crush I'll go on
other people's shows and pull big ass
numbers for them
because like oh content creators bring
an audience it's because you guys get to
see it's BTS it's your favorite actor by
the way
it's not acting and it's everyday and
it's all their life not just the show so
you're like oh I really connect with
this person imagine if you can if Steve
Urkel at the end of the show was like
all right guys we're gonna go back all
right all right so you know I'm going to
the store today like yo I love Julia
white so much more see that guy he was
at the story guy he bought the same ice
cream I do or
it's vlogging so
um that's what we're gonna go for that's
in the next couple months are gonna be
content creators that's what we're going
to strive to get yes we're gonna get our
artists and rappers musicians I get that
but that's what we're gonna we're gonna
aim toward a little more stuff that we
watch people we see we just wanna I
don't know I don't know what we're
saying me and Mario can do this all day
and never have another guess in life
sure but
we're not going to do that yeah
uh
well yeah that's everything we've been
here for a while two and a half hours
yeah so this is a weird week we're
prepared for our best episode but we've
been prepared for a guest for three days
in a row
John bitched out John bitched out we had
a backup guest they lagged and the
backup gas light again and then but this
morning they go how about next week
not their fault we're asking them to do
us a favor I'm just saying the timing
I'm only talking about what happened in
real time [__] the timing up really bad
excuse me and Mari like oh so you have
48 hours to edit this
and then that song Double make
double minute come down
and it's Marty distress and [__]
editing with [__] joints bro nothing
gets to you yeah ripping tails off
Marty
what you just see the [__] blackness
I like it just painted a picture
I [__] with it I like it all God
sometimes I wish we had an animator we
could animate at all that
I'm gonna plug that into [__] chat
GPT and see what happens
we'll make an animation video editor
[__] rips bong as cat and background
terrorist tale lizard oh try that I like
that silhouette
man whatever was in those joints was
[__] some it was cbx's all their
newfinos good [__] look at our Twitter
for some BTS of that [__] oh go follow
our Twitter the dopest usual podcast
Twitter post whatever the [__] we want
we're back post all weed [__] we post
whatever we want check out our our Tick
Tock dope as usual on Tick Tock one of
our Clips are like 180 000 views and we
don't do we don't even use it so that's
awesome thank you
that's super cool oh
remember that video I posted remember
the story I told you guys when I went to
go pick up my car from getting wrapped
and the guy's like
this is your car yo I follow you that's
why it smells like weed now that makes
sense like oh no way the whole time like
God who is this guy he smokes so much
weed this car he's like oh I follow him
actually remember that I thought it was
really funny yeah
I posted that little clip on on YouTube
and YouTube did not age restrict it
three million views damn
in a week
I know when something goes viral is when
all the really mean random things start
being said I went in there just I was
like the next day I go
200 000 likes
like what what and I clicked it go oh
the what
oh because I didn't smoke I'm not
showing weed I'm not [__] saying
terrible things
YouTube likes that and I went and the
comment went whoa
that's how I know something popped off
when people are just insane people
saying the weirdest [__] that doesn't
make any sense this is what's wrong with
America Chinese taking over our country
or something stupid like bro what are
you talking about it's just me talking
about getting high
people say the weirdest [__] when it's
when it's like open Forum yeah it's not
just our friends yeah oh my God
it is the craziest [__] and I love it
[__] fat kid probably driving his
dad's car I love that one I get that
hundreds of times
but that's good because I could just
block a lot of people at once it's fun
that that's good it's like a cleansing
of my channel no because when those
people realize what the actual deal is
if they were to just dig beneath they
don't care because they were you know
they don't even if they're like yo
that's the guy that saved your mom when
she was a child like oh I [__] that
guy still it doesn't matter yeah it does
not matter to them but yeah people oh
man
that yeah anyway that video went viral
as you could say and uh
yeah YouTube comment section is insane I
forgot I haven't had a a short goal off
like that because almost just weed I
haven't had to do that in a long time
since you signed the dude's dashboard
oh yeah on Twitter on YouTube yeah
because I can't post anything on YouTube
shorts it's all gets flagged I have like
50 shorts and only 10 of them show 40 of
them are hidden because it's not
friendly content it did that to the
podcast it won't even show up on my page
it can be Asian but it won't even show
up I've noticed that I thought it was
glitching no it it's it's you don't even
show yeah so you can't even check the
analytics because it's not really there
it's crazy anyway guys sorry to rant
about nothing here we go here you go sir
oh [__] here you go sir
I just feel like I don't know I just
want to give a bunch of [__] away I did
a stash Dash in Merced where I left like
a little
almost a little quarter worth of some
fire because Clinic I just left in the
gas station nice like come get it
somebody come grab it
and I just feel like I need to do that
more I used to like QPS ounces just
random [__] everywhere I'm like I'm at
the corner of so-and-so I'm in Modesto
California come get it first person to
show up and just like yo did I really
just get two sips
imagine you're sitting at home just
scrolling go that's outside the stream
and you go get two Zips when you were
just hanging out mm-hmm
I think they would be made yeah of
course what [__] you know so that's why
I like it's like an angel yeah I like
doing stash of Dash because of that
reason
so I need to do more of them
here we go
chip
do I
[Music]
oh God
it's American made
it is I don't know what that hit though
I got it
all right all right guys before we get
out of here
oh my God
before he got here
over the screen of Marty boom
that's his Instagram that's his Twitter
and his YouTube channel go watch that go
follow that that's Bo Marty made it all
over his screen
oh yeah
boom over my screen my Instagram my
Snapchat my YouTube my Twitter
I'm a damn Tick Tock yo I appealed the
video for tick tock today and one same
for the podcast
let's go yeah all I did was talk showed
nothing and they flagged it because I
said 1200 milligrams or something hmm
Jesus Christ you know what's crazy right
after that
straight up whole naked ass everything
some girls show like some girls like
working out and it flashed and it was
like a naked butt naked picture of her
and it goes better pause quick
I'll I'll post it Rosie's seen it
I'm gonna show my blocked list on on
tick tock
I block like 20 people a day they did
nothing wrong to me I just think their
content is garbage oh [__] I blocked so
many [__] girls every day
why do you pop up on my page
I don't want to see that and it pops up
on my [__] page I've never thought to
block somebody I block them instantly
it's always girls that are doing this
if you look at the mirror they're butt
[__] naked showing their whole ass or
showing their whole [__] vat like
completely butt [__] naked and go
how do you post this and I naked
pictures is sick
I'm not saying you're gross I'm saying
for principal reasons you need to be
blocked
how the [__] can you post your bare
[__] body
I can't I can't say the words 1200
milligrams
I block you for principles not because
you're ugly also yo this is like what
kind of app is this [__] the [__] you
guys know what I'm talking about to
you've seen those stupid [__] if you
haven't seen him already it's crazy
oh my God I can't stand it it's like
only fans girls found a hack
you know do your thing
I don't want you in my page [__] block
I don't want to see this stupid [__] for
tick tock though like kids on there yeah
yeah I know there's a reason why there's
a million likes on it go there's a
million likes on the post
I got fired in 30 seconds
yeah it doesn't even make sense
it's okay because the guy from earlier
that controls the world and went hey you
billionaires fight
he's the guy going hey no it doesn't
make sense
delete delete the [__] account or
release the pictures of you and your
[__] wife's friend release this
[__] you know what I mean
delete it delete it you know that vidmio
[__] delete that too
oh his bank account make it not match
his social security number for a month
no I know he's had it for his whole life
make it not [__] mess [__] that's
what they're doing the guy that controls
the Earth's coin there's a lot of
positivity coming out of this one over
here and it's [__] up my [__]
you wouldn't think it would work like
that something's going on bro because
the fact that I get [__] with you I
mean we've talked about it too many
times
we did it I've been talking to YouTube
on the email
oh really and every time I get them in a
bind passing it over to CJ
CJ here I say some [__] to him passing
it over to Tyler Tyler here they've done
six different four different people
already and this last one I just told
him like so I'll be sure to say CJ was
no help in the article that I get
written
because at this point oh would I tell
you they respond to me like humans like
at this point I'm gonna call [__]
discrimination I don't know what and
they said hey
this has nothing to do with your
ethnicity I promise you that a real
person spoke to me on YouTube
screenshot open
screenshot right over the screen I'm
putting my last let's do it or maybe we
shouldn't we are on their platform right
now you know what no screenshot over the
screen
anyway CJ was like I promise you it has
nothing to do with your ethnicity and I
just let him have it again I'm like then
you tell me why
over to Tyler
Tyler she is four people about the
fourth guy they said usually takes 29 to
30 days to review your pace for
verification
it's been 65 days oh that's what's like
the issue that you're pressing that's
where the adventures of Yola channel to
get monetized gotcha because they flag
different drug content
and I hit him up drug content can you
please review it after reviewing we see
that your account does violate terms go
where please tell me where violence
terms that's insane it's it and that's
why I posted I've actually come to the
conclusion it makes no sense there is no
logic
the level that we took to not have
anything on that channel was extreme
like it was there was no mess-ups even
to point at like
whatsoever so I feel like it's Shawshank
Redemption and I'm the guy that's gonna
testify and the internet is the fool
with the rifle and they're like you're
gonna do it
all right all right I'm gonna take this
one down too bam One account oh you're
gonna say Sir [__] you
and I'll be on account [__] Infinity
[Music]
who cares there's people like uh William
Randolph Hearst out there
you know who that be
the dude that made weed legal originally
people that they I should have known it
their interests are compromised by the
further and so of weed and [__]
oh yeah yeah I see that
also
we're gonna leave that last note there's
probably that space you see that space
we'll leave that note off
I know you really want to go in I know
you really want to go in on that topic
just like something else that's going to
be going in
but I don't think we should talk about
that
I think we're gonna leave that one up
for interpretation on this
I don't think we should do that you know
why
that's not us
I mean it could be that's pretty funny
you know what that's ammo if anything
ever goes sideways go oh we want to talk
[__] oh
till that day I think we should just be
nice people yeah of course because if I
was in those shoes
and then us talked about it no I'd be
like yo
I I was getting it from all angles
can't get away from it did you like that
play on Joe I didn't want to go too far
but yes getting it from all angles here
we're gonna leave that one's B that's
insane that's crazy
what the hell is happening on Earth
right now we're gonna leave that one be
it's just this bill's Stadium lizard
tale all caps
what the [__]
I'm looking at Marty's notes lizard tail
Bill Stadium
Jesus Christ
that's all I got folks oh dude almost a
three hour episode we didn't do anything
we just sat here and talked about
nothing which is great
it's the best times but you know what
hurry up John
for real you need to get in here hurry
up stop being a little [__]
um fans been waiting nachos this past
week where we were supposed to go but
this past [__] six months at least
hurry up uh we're working a lot of big
guests so yes we'll leave it we'll leave
it be once again guys thank you so much
for being here if you're still here drop
a like notification Bell subscribe all
that fun stuff we have been here for
almost three hours like I said talking
about about just about nothing Marty's
family is in Buffalo so Marty's gonna
hang out tonight we're gonna go to my
house depending on what time it is
no we're gonna go straight to dinner
we're gonna go straight to dinner from
here and then uh
yeah we'll be hanging out guys thank you
so much for being here really appreciate
you rolled up that weekend my nose
completely stuffed I was waiting for it
you made it a while you can hear it like
my nose is completely stuffed damn it
guys thank you so much I know I said
that 60 times I'm very high in burnt and
edible doubt thank you Marty anything
else you got to say thank you guys feel
so good to be back I feel rejuvenated
about to really take office next month
I'm excited thank you guys
oh we're about to do Spotify commercials
too
all right if you hear our voices that
that's us
all right and uh sign up for us or so
sign up subscribe to us on Spotify
follow our Channel press a heart
whatever you do for support we
appreciate you guys shout out to Spotify
for making this official brand Partners
we appreciate you guys thank you so much
a lot more coming out with Spotify thank
you for being on our side all right
YouTube dick
um yeah that's it
good I'm good thank you guys I'm good oh
man those Edibles man
I feel just
still just wavy is from being so sleepy
and [__]
I I I I I couldn't tell you how long
we've been here if that clock was in
here I would have said it would be 45.
couldn't tell you there's no sunlight
we're in a Vegas hotel or a Vegas casino
in here
all right maybe it could have been the
ball hits too but we'll be all right
thank you guys for being here thank you
so much this has been the dope as usual
podcast we appreciate you we're here we
talked about life drugs problems
accomplishments and my grandma not
liking my uncle's wife bunch of fun
hilarious things
I'll tell you everything as soon as we
get off it is insane gotcha thank you
it's [__] crazy
guys thank you so much for being here I
really appreciate you from Mario O'Neill
from myself we appreciate you for
watching have a dope ass day
oh my God
hold a Seinfeld
show about nothing
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect